bonjour à tous et bienvenue en direct
sur public sénat voici les titres 2
sénat 360
suite de l'examen de la loi pacte au
sénat ce texte ambitionne de transformer
les entreprises
le sénat s'attaque cette après midi au
volet concernant l'épargné retraite des
salariés
explications dans un instant et hier en
séance le sénat est revenu sur
l'interdiction du plastique dans les
contenants alimentaires
est ce un nouveau recul en matière
d'environnement après les déclarations
d' emmanuel macron sur le glyphosate
on ouvre le débat dans cette édition la
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement c'est à suivre en direct et
en exclusivité dès 15h sur notre antenne
parmi les thèmes la réforme de la
justice après l'audition de la garde des
sceaux
hier par la commission des lois
et je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
réagir à cette émission avec le hashtag
sénat 360 et pour m'accompagner
on retrouvera également alexandre
poussin rétame traduit pour vous faire
vivre la séance et pour toutes les
réactions des sénateurs à l'actualité
aujourd'hui dans votre multiplexe et on
prend tout de suite à la direction de
l'hémicycle justement nous attend
alexandre poussa je le disais alexandre
l'examen de la loi pacte aura lieu après
la séance de questions d'actualité
et oui delphine et dans cette fois pas
qu on va parler d'un point important du
texte la réforme de les pannes de
l'épargne-retraite ces produits
d'épargné retraite complète les revenus
des régimes de retraite obligatoires et
des retraites complémentaires le
problème c'est que les français boudent
aujourd'hui les pannes
l'épargne-retraite quelques centaines de
milliards d'euros sont actuellement en
cours est détenu par les français
cette réforme elle vise à rendre plus
attractifs ces produits d'épargné
tous les détenteurs de ces produits
d'épargné retraite pour ont liquidé à
tout moment leur épargne pour acheter
une résidence principale
et puis il ya aussi une harmonisation de
toutes les règles des différents
produits proposés par les établissements
bancaires il ya la création d'une
portabilité total du produit d'épargné
retraite et enfin cette réforme vise à
améliorer le rendement de ces produits
en essayant d'encourager la détente la
détention d'actifs sur des
investissements à long terme et en
favorisant la concurrence des
établissements financiers
merci beaucoup pour vos précisions
alexandre l'on prend la direction de la
salle des conférences ont des attentes
sam trains de nuit à une heure de la
séance des questions d'actualité tam
vous aurez de nombreux invités à votre
micro
oui effectivement delphine nous allons
avec eux parler d'abord environnement
alors qu'il ya des reculs qui s'annonce
de la part du gouvernement notamment sur
la question de l'interdiction du
glyphosate alors qu'ils également et
bien hier des mesures plutôt défavorable
à l'environnement ont été adoptées au
détour de la loi impact cela avec
parfois la bénédiction de l'exécutif
j'en parlerai notamment avec le sénateur
les indépendants jérôme bignon
il sera aussi bien sûr question de cette
fameuse loi pacte ce projet de loi
quelque peu fourre-tout pour la
croissance et la transformation des
entreprises qui est débattu cette
semaine et la semaine prochaine au sénat
à mon micro et bien il y aura le
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
qui défend ce texte dans l'hémicycle
j'interroge notamment sur la question
des privatisations contenues dans le
texte des privatisations d'ailleurs
auquel le sénateur l'est républicain
philippe dominati et lui fermement
opposée il sera à lui aussi à mon micro
dans une demi heure
enfin au programme est bien le non cumul
des mandats alors que l'exécutif envoie
des signaux pour un assouplissement de
cette règle avec des dérogations pour
les maires des petites villes
on en parlera avec le sénateur l'est
républicain gérard longuet ainsi qu'avec
et bien le ministre des relations avec
le parlement marc fesneau
merci beaucoup au tam pour ce programme
et après la hausse annoncée de certains
prix alimentaires
voilà un nouveau casse tête pour les
pouvoirs publics cette fois ce sont
allés prix à de l'électricité qui vont
augmenter le régulateur propose en effet
une hausse de 6 % des tarifs réglementés
batterie ce faisant le gouvernement
l'avait suspendu en décembre la
commission de régulation de l'énergie en
reparle en janvier et propose une forte
hausse des tarifs de l'électricité + 5,9
pour cent
toutes taxes comprises pour les
consommateurs cela représente une hausse
de 85 euros par an pour un foyer se
chauffant à l'électricité et une hausse
de 25 euros pour les autres ménages
au total 25,6 millions de foyers abonnés
au tarif bleu d'edf vont être touchés
par cette hausse qui est l'une des plus
fortes de ces dernières années pour la
droite c'est une aberration
trop de taxes frappe l'énergie je crois
qu'il est grand temps qu en terme de
taxe de manière diverse et surtout sur
l'énergie on refonde je dirais le
dispositif c'est un impératif parce que
la colère des français doit être entendu
elle doit être entendue par pour tous
les français évidemment pour celles et
ceux qui sont dans une situation
difficile mais également pour les autres
parce que la france aujourd'hui elle a
besoin d'unir ses forces et de ne pas se
diviser
elle a besoin de réparer des fractures
et non pas d'accentuer les différences
dans un contexte social déjà très
fragilisé avec le mouvement des gilet
jaune commencé en novembre et qui ne
faiblit pas cette proposition risque de
mal passer la commission de régulation
ou encore consulter les associations de
consommateurs et divers fournisseurs
d'énergie avant de se prononcer
définitivement
le 7 février prochain le gouvernement
aura alors trois mois pour valider ou
s'opposer à cette augmentation
dans le reste de l'actualité les chaînes
de fast-food priés de mettre de l'ordre
dans leurs poubelles brune poisson a
reçu ce matin tous les dirigeants des
chaînes de restauration rapide
la secrétaire d'état entend bien
rappeler les obligations légales à ces
mauvais élèves du tri des déchets genre
d'un éclat la réunion a duré environ une
heure
autour de la table les patrons des
grandes chaînes de fast-food mcdonald's
subway ou burger king convoqué par le
secrétariat d'état à l'écologie pour
leur rappeler leurs obligations en
matière de tri des déchets en effet
après des contrôles dans une
cinquantaine de points de vente des
manquements graves à la réglementation
ont été constatés aucune salle de
restauration n'était en conformité
totale avec l'ensemble de la
réglementation et la législation
par exemple aucune des salles de
restauration effectués c'est le tri des
déchets en salle de restauration pour
certaines c'était en cuisine avec
environ 160 mille tonnes de déchets
générés chaque année en france dans les
fast-foods les efforts consentis en
matière de recyclage sont trop faibles
souligne la ministre
par exemple sur 1400 mcdonald's que
compte l'hexagone seuls 70 recycle
vraiment le problème qui se pose dans
les restaurants c'est que
ils resteront n'ont pas tous la même
taille n'ont pas tous la même
disposition et qu'il était parfois
difficile de mettre davantage de
poubelles par ailleurs se pose un
problème de logistique de récupération
des déchets parce que trier c'est bien
mais il faut valoriser les déchets et
donc cette valorisation implique
l'ensemble des partenaires de la filière
jusqu'aux récupérateur qui ensuite
doivent les valoriser sous notre
contrôle
une nouvelle réunion est prévue début
avril si la ministre constate encore des
manquements graves en matière de tri
sélectif
elle se réserve alors le droit de
divulguer publiquement les noms des
mauvais élèves et on retourne la salle
des conférences où on retrouve donc tu
as me traduit pour la réaction du
sénateur a les indépendants 11 / ame
bignon à cette initiative de la
secrétaire d'état bruno poisson oui on a
entendu brune par son qui annonce une
initiative sur les déchets des fast food
mais plus globalement est-ce que vous
jugez que le gouvernement est dans une
attitude de renoncement par rapport aux
sujets environnementaux car il ya des
reculs sur le glyphosate le nikkei est
clair bien encore hier et bien on a vu
en sciences sur la question des
ustensiles plastique à usage unique
sauf que le renoncement est un mot un
peu violent peut-être plus des reculs ou
en tout cas des temporisation parce que
entre le lait fed annonce qui est
toujours derrière toute activité
gouvernementale toute activité
d'opposition toutes activités des ong il
faut pouvoir obtenir de crantée une
décision et puis le moment le moment on
doit le mettre en application finalement
les difficultés de scientifiques
difficultés technologiques les
difficultés de mise sur le marché les
difficultés elles mêmes difficultés de
mise sur le marché de nouveaux produits
il faut de nouveaux contrôles il ya des
recours c'est tout est d'une complexité
extrême et cet univers va trop vite pour
prendre des décisions sereines est ce
que justement n'est pas tout le temps en
train de reculer les échéances et cela
peut faire vraiment détriment de cette
transition ben c'est sûr que puisse plus
vite on pourrait aller mieux ce serait
pour la santé publique pour le pour le
monde mais
faut être capable de le tenir aussi le
problème c'est que visiblement on n'est
pas aussi capable le conte le qu'on le
souhaiterait probablement gouvernement
préférerait dire distance il en
plastique on les supprime parce que
c'est pas bon pour la nature
tout le monde le sait si on le fait pas
c'est pas pour enquiquiner les dans
l'hémicycle aujourd'hui certains faire
valoir et bien les emplois que ceux là
bas ça se dit par exemple sur les
bouteilles en blanc bouteilles en
plastique on dit ben voila si on
supprime livre d'embouteillage en
plastique pour les zones as-tu les eaux
minérales
il y aura plus d'eau minérale on va
perdre des emplois et ses envies et ses
contraintes existent et le problème
c'est le gouverner c'est tout le temps
essayer d'arbitrer entre le plus grand
et le plus grand avantage est le plus
petit inconvénient c'est ça c'est ça qui
est forcément compliqué moi je suis pas
l'air spécialement pour dire que la
moiteur gouvernement a raison que les
ong ont tort ou à raison
j'essaye de regarder je mesure que c'est
difficile c'est tout homme qui fait
quelque chose a contre lui tous ceux qui
voudraient faire le plus vite mieux et
puis il ya surtout l'immense foule de
ceux qui ne font rien lear qui râlent
très fort il faut bien trouver des
priorités lorsqu'on aura notamment dans
l'impact des déchets plastiques sur les
océans vos piètres servant lui il
défenseurs de la biodiversité un
chéquier ça je suis malheureux quand je
plonge je vois bien sûr vous avez bien
sûr bien sûr mais mais d'abord ya tueur
ce regard qu'on a on est un ce1 % de
l'humanité est bon donc que font tous
les autres il faut aussi donner du
collectif sur ces sujets là il faut
travailler ensemble on voit qu'il ya
beaucoup de résistance et beaucoup de
pays européens
on n'arrive pas à se mettre d'accord
avec les pays européens sur beaucoup de
sujets concernant l'environnement
concernant l'écologie concerne les
produits phyto donc il y à il ya un élan
et c'est vrai que c'est très très
compliqué et parfois nos compatriotes ne
refus nous nous reproche de faire tout
seul cavalier seul alors que les autres
ne font rien pourquoi renonce tong ou au
carbone alors que les allemands les
polonais continuaient à se régaler avec
du charbon dont kiel il ya cette espèce
de difficulté permanente à la fois
d'aller vers le progrès de le faire tous
ensemble de trouver les technologies moi
j'essaye d'avoir un peu d'indulgence
merci beaucoup gérant bien
répondu à mes questions merci beaucoup
tam et vous venez d'en parler nucléaire
glyphosate est maintenant plastique
après une année 2010 8 marqué par le
départ de nicolas hulot l'année 2019
devait être placée sous le signe de
l'engagement en matière d'environnement
en témoigne le succès de la pétition
pour le climat mais depuis trois
semaines à les tergiversations du
gouvernement ont semé le doute avant
d'en parler avec mes invités on voit
tout de suite ce sujet de ces sections
faille assiettes et couverts en
plastique ne les arrange et pas tout de
suite les sénateurs ont voté hier avec
le soutien du gouvernement un amendement
qui repoussent leur interdiction d'un an
nous sommes pour tous les progrès en
faveur de l'environnement
mais nous rappelons madame la présidente
que dans l'environnement il existe aussi
l'espèce humaine et que cette espèce
humaine elle a besoin de travailler
l'environnement qui passent au second
plan le gouvernement multiplie en tout
cas les rétro pédalage sur ses
engagements écologiques comme ce 25
janvier quand emmanuel macron s'est
invitée dans un grand débat dans la
drôme
il est revenu sur sa promesse d'éliminer
le glyphosate dans les trois ans autre
reculade celle de françois de rugy le
ministre de l'environnement fervents
opposants au nucléaire il a rangé ses
discours violent et s'est adoucie en
déclarant lundi lors de la signature
d'un contrat stratégique avec la filière
que le nucléaire joue un rôle important
dans la stratégie énergétique de la
france dans laquelle il a sa place face
aux promesses écologiques les
contraintes économiques sont elles
devenues trop forte
en tout cas en répondant à la pression
économique le gouvernement prend le
risque de s'éloigner des demandes
sociétales exprimé par exemple par la
pétition la sphère du siècle signé par
plus de 2 millions personnes et en
ouvrent à tout de suite le débat dans
sénat 360 avec mes invités sur ce
plateau
mounir marc durando pardon vous êtes
chercheur à l'université paris saclay et
membre de transition écologie en marche
également sur ce plateau mounir satouri
bonjour 7 le président du groupe
alternative écologiste et sociale au
conseil régional d'ile-de-france
bienvenue à vous également sur ce
plateau de guillaume gontard vous êtes
sénateur de te rattaché au groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes sénateur de l'isère et puis
jean bizet c'est également avec nous
avec le président de la commission des
affaires européennes
ici au sénat au sénat les sénateurs l
ère de la manse première question pour
vous guillaume montaron je le disais
2018 avait été marqué par le départ
notamment de nicolas hulot c'était le
synonyme pour beaucoup des reculs du
gouvernement en matière de protection de
l'environnement 2019 partait sous de
bons auspices avec cette pétition ça a
été rappelée qui a réuni à plus de deux
millions de personnes et puis tout d'un
coup patatras
qu'est ce qui s'est passé selon vos bas
deux parties sous de bons auspices en
tout cas c'est vrai qu'avec le départ de
nicolas hulot cet électrochoc je pense
que tout le monde avait compris que
cette cette politique ce qu'il appelait
la politique des petits pas ne
fonctionnait plus et qu'il fallait agir
qu'il faut aller il fallait vraiment
prendre les choses en main et on voit
que là on est sûr reculade en reculade
est-ce qui est ce qui est vraiment
dramatique on l'a vu encore hier soir
avec ce qui a été voté ce qui a été voté
au sénat que ce soit sur l'espèce
pesticides que ça soit sur sur le recul
par rapport à l'interdiction des des
ustensiles en plastique
on l'a vu sur le glyphosate et on vient
de le voir avec ce qu'a annoncé emmanuel
macron qui est quand même un mensonge en
direct puisque on nous avait promis moi
j'avais pu débattre avec même ministre
travers qui m'avait promis les yeux dans
les yeux que l'on retiendrait ont tiré
en tiendrait ces trois ans sur le
glyphosate quand on a essayé de le
mettre dans la loi on nous a dit non il
n'y a pas besoin de le mettre dans la
loi on tiendra ses trois ans et puis ben
voilà on voit bien qu'on recule et je
pense qu'en fait derrière tout ça c'est
qu'on ne donne même pas c'est pas c'est
pas un gage qu'on donne aux entreprises
parce qu'au contraire on leur permet de
continuer de continuer comme avant et
ailleurs parce qu'on parle souvent de
l'europe
ailleurs on a des entreprises qui avance
qui innovent et qui savent prendre ce
virage et je pense que là on fait une
grave erreur et qu'on emmène nos
entreprises droit dans le mur jean bizet
ce que le gouvernement est moins
ambitieux selon vous en ce début d'année
en matière de protection de
l'environnement en matière d'engagement
en faveur du climat
je pense que le le gouvernement prend
conscience du principe de réalité si
vous voulez vous avez fait référence
tout à l'heure à nicolas hulot est un
bel esprit je l'occasion de l'approcher
c'était pas parmi les ministres et
quelques elle j'avais des contacts les
plus fréquents mais en fait c'est un
grand communicant qui a dû mal à
accepter le principe de réalité dans ce
cas de figure il s'enfuit il est parti
on vous on dit souvent qu'il ne faut
plus opposés jean bizet écologie à
l'économie justement le débat encore
hier en sciences en drapé sur cette
question de l'interdiction du plastique
et bien sûr il faut surtout pas les
opposer moi j'ai toujours été le
partisan si je puis dire pour régler la
problématique environnementale qui est
essentiel de faire des sauts
technologiques
en ce qui concerne le plastique nous
avons eu autrefois des débats qu'on n'a
jamais pu arriver à faire aboutir et a
tranché passer du plastique à des
technologies de fabrication à partir du
végétal qui sont biodégradables et bien
ça suppose également des mutations
je dirais techno
logique forte qui ne s'accompagnerait
pas dans un moyen terme ou à long terme
si vous les destructions d'emploi mais
encore une fois là il faut sortir si je
puis dire d'un certain nombre de
sectarisme marquez girondeau où est
passé emmanuel macron qui disait mec
planet green it again on s'en souvient
c'était ce qu'il avait dit au président
donald trump sévissent à cette période
alors je pense que déjà c'est pas fini
puisque tout ce qui est climat le plan
pourrait annuel sur l'énergie a au
contraire renforcé renforcer un certain
nombre d'idées sur le sujet pour revenir
sur le plastique
oui il y a un retard d'un an qui a été
acté pour se caler sur l'union
européenne
c'était la même chose avec les sacs
plastiques les sacs plastiques 2016 donc
branle-bas-de-combat on demande un an
finalement un an a été accordé et on a
supprimé les sacs plastiques
il va se passer la même chose bien sûr
moi je préfère l'idée c'est
effectivement on est dans une période
relativement troubles il faut quand même
essayer de ne pas mettre tout le monde
les uns contre les autres
oui le plastique sera supprimée avec un
an de retard
c'est évident que moi j'aurais préféré
aussi qu'on supprime le plus tôt
possible
j'ai organisé le world clean up des
dents dans ma ville je dois dire que
dans la forêt de meudon chaville on a
ramassé pas mal de plastique
c'est évident que qu'il faut se
débarrasser de ce plastique jetables
le plastique dans les océans n'est pas
une thématique française le plasticien
des océans est plus une thématique
asiatiques qui arrivent par les courants
chez nous donc chez nous on a un
problème sur la termes de co2
d'utilisation de produits pétroliers qui
conduit au plastique c'est pas un
problème
artix et 70 à 80% des résidus marins à
l'est
le plastique non je suis entièrement
d'accord mais ils viennent de chine
d'inde ils viennent pas de france en
france la gestion des déchets ce fait
comme correctement
mounir saturé et pourtant on voit bien
la difficulté pour le gouvernement c'est
début d'année marqué par une crise
sociale par ce mouvement d gilet jaune
on se souvient de cette phrase qui
résume un peu le dilemme pour le
gouvernement
vous nous parlez fin du monde et nous
parle fins de mois alors qu'en réalité
on peut concilier les deux je crois que
le réalisme a changé de camp je crois
qu'aujourd'hui le réalisme c'est de
penser qu'on ne peut plus dégradé
l'environnement est pollué les sols et
l'océan
le réalisme c'est de dire qu'on ne peut
plus être dans un modèle agricole qui
polluent les sols qui rend malade les
agriculteurs et les appauvrit le
réalisme c'est de penser qu'on ne peut
plus laisser ce modèle de développement
rouler à toute vitesse vers du n'importe
quoi en réalité les alternatives sur nos
territoires monsieur le sénateur n
existe qu on en sort de sa bulle et
qu'on va voir sur le terrain on voit des
entreprises qui innovent
on voit qu'il ya une agriculture
différente qui nourrit beaucoup mieux
les françaises et les français qui
donnent beaucoup plus d'emplois aux
agricultrices et aux agriculteurs et qui
permet une rentabilité meilleure que le
modèle dominant aujourd'hui
donc en réalité ce vieil adage on on
peut pas faire la transition parce que
il y aurait menace à l'emploi moi je
pense que ce gouvernement comme les
autres est prisonnier des lobbyistes
en réalité il ya des intérêts très
particuliers pour certains partout dans
notre pays
le génie français fait qu'on innove et
qu'on construit des alternatives ce dont
on a besoin c'est d'aider ces
alternatives
parce que vous croyez qu'on reculant de
2 ans la fin des plastiques non
réutilisables ça va j'en sais quoi que
ce soit à la transition moi je pense qu
on acte ans aujourd'hui le fait de
sortir de cela et on est dans les
filières à s'accélérer
on est dans l'innovation a avancé et bah
on donne de la vence à nos entreprises
les alternatifs existent il suffit de
les soutenir et de les organiser et ce
gouvernement
à chaque fois que la question de
l'urgence environnement
je lui ai posé il actionne la marche
arrière c'est un désastre pour notre
pays et pour la place que depuis la côte
21 on est censé occuper en europe et
dans le monde
est-ce que ce message ait encore
entendable par les français par les
citoyens qui s'inquiète aussi de leur
pouvoir d'achat
guillaume gontard ben moi je pense qu'il
est complètement entend table et
d'ailleurs quand on voit dans la rue
vous avez parlé de la marche pour climat
du du mouvement pour les avec les
coquelicots et tous ces mouvements là je
pense qu'il ya une vraie attente et moi
je rejoins ce qui a été dit je pense
qu'il faut enfin être réaliste et
pragmatique et le réalisme et le
pragmatisme et ben c'est de ces de
regarder ce qui se passe on le voit sur
le plastique alors vous disiez que le
plastique français n'est pas forcément
dans les océans
il suffit de faire des analyses dans
l'eau du robinet on retrouve des
particules de plastique saas etc
c'est la réalité sur les pesticides on
voit toutes les études on voit que tout
le monde est touché les agriculteurs en
premier plan donc on a besoin de changer
on doit changer
et la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on a les
solutions et les solutions existent et
qu'en plus elle apporte du travail à
tout le monde donc je pense qu'il faut
être réaliste plus votre pragmatique et
qu'il faut y aller et qu'il faut agir
toute façon je dirais qu'on a plus le
choix on doit l'on doit le faire donc
moi je pense qu'il faut vraiment
vraiment qu'on change cette manière
cette manière de voir cette manière de
penser qu'ils nous mais attention le
travail on prend l'exemple des sacs
plastiques l'interdiction des sacs
plastique ça crée des emplois et exemple
et sympathique ça crée des emplois
pourquoi parce que sacs plastiques
venaient d'asie venaient de chine et que
on a créé une filière une filière locale
pour créer des bioplastiques
donc voilà changeons notre manière de
voir et soyons réalistes s'enliser jour
et nous entendre sur le dos et un du
glyphosate puisqu'on a réentendu la
déclaration un emmanuel macron dans la
drôme pour lui et bien même en trois ans
dit il on ne fera pas 100% on n'y
arrivera pas je ne pense pas qu'on y
arrive
c'est ça le principe de réalité que vous
évoquiez il ya un instant le glyphosate
permettez-moi d'être extrêmement carré
sur le sujet nous sommes dans un plein
délire médiatique quand on considère si
je puis dire la réalité scientifique
vous avez les choses at il est dangereux
ou il ne l'est pas s'il est dangereux
c'est pas trois ans cinq en quinze ans
c'est tout de suite qu'il faut
l'interdire
mais ce n'est pas clos mais il faut sur
la question est-ce qu'il est dangereux
et principes de près du bord j'en étais
le rapporteur je pourrais vous en parler
pendant des heures
réponse onze agences de santé nationales
européennes ou de pays tiers 11 sur 12
ont dit le glyphosate n'est pas
dangereux une seule
le centre international de recherche
contre le cancer
relié à l'om c'est à l'om est ce pardon
disait de lui vanter a répondu c'est un
cancérigène supposés ils l'ont placé en
place à deux au même titre que la
charcuterie le café ou le chaude
alors quand est-ce que nous allons
interdire maxi la charcuterie est faible
jourdain c'est tout voilà c'est tout
votre réponse alors vous entendez ces
arguments oui alors la première chose on
n'a pas de plastique dans l'eau du
robinet pense que c'est pas possible
donc là il ya un petit problème sur le
sujet sur le glyphosate sur le
glyphosate ce que vous dites vous parler
de la santé humaine
depuis décembre 2018 on a une étude sur
l'impact du glyphosate sur les bactéries
qui vivent à l'intérieur des abeilles et
qui est très clair qui montre qu'il ya
un effet donc c'est ce qui a échappé à
la vigilance de l'étude de l'insee bah
oui tout simplement parce que leurs
études c'est 2016 ça a été publié en
décembre 2018
il ya un problème il ya un problème du
glyphosate en terme de biodiversité donc
côté santé humaine je vous rejoins côté
biodiversité non on a un problème il va
falloir s'en sortir on a eu un rapport
de l'inra président de macron et le
gouvernement a demandé à l'inra je ne
peux pas être classée comme étant ong
donc en gros des gens très sérieux qui
utilisaient publications existantes qui
dit il y à quelques domaines où on ne
pourra pas encore sortir du glyphosate
donc oui je pense que 90 % on peut
sortir du glyphosate il ya quelques
domaines particuliers ou ne peut pas en
sortir pour la santé humaine il renier
ses engagements elle emmanuel macron sur
ce point et notamment stéphane travert
l'ancien ministre de l'agriculture
je peux pas dire le contraire un cadre
non seulement c'est donc effectivement
on plaint des belges il a demandé un
rapport à l'inra sur la faisabilité
l'inra a dit oui dans 90% des cas on
peut sortir il ya 10% des cas où on n'a
pas d'alternative à la manière c'est que
le débat devient intenable pour ceux qui
défendent le vieux modèle agricole
on leur en technique en fait il faut
arrêter d'abord pendant des centaines
d'années l'humanité n'avait pas besoin
des produits chimiques pour se nourrir
et je l'aï dit tout à l'heure et je suis
désolé de le répéter
aujourd'hui il ya plein d'agricole qui
ont réussi leur reconversion il y en a
d'autres qui sont en transition qui
réduisent de manière drastique
l'utilisation de produits chimiques
et vous savez quoi ça fonctionne c'est
rentable
ils nourrissent mieux nos concitoyens et
gagnent mieux leur vie
donc ça suffit mais jusqu'à quand vous
allez continuer à tenir sous perfusion
ce système qui agrafes la biodiversité
qui détruit les terres qui rend malade
les utilisateurs les agriculteurs
aujourd'hui 100 malades de ce système et
ils ne gagnent pas suffisamment leur vie
donc à un moment donné il faut arrêter
on a une responsabilité d'activer la
transition et de changer de modèle
agricole est en baisse à se jouera au
niveau européen puisque la pac va être
ont négocié et on a besoin d'avoir
suffisamment d'être suffisamment présent
efforts pour changer l'agriculture à
l'échelon clairement emmanuel macron il
s'assure un salon agriculture tranquille
par ses déclarations il ya aussi de la
politique politicienne dans vos têtes
sans doute mais je peux pas entendre si
vous voulez ce que vient de dire
l'intervenant précédentes c'est
peut-être ça le problème mais non le
problème est pas entendre non mais si
vous voulez moi je viens du milieu
agricole pendant une vingtaine d'années
si vous voulez j'ai côtoyé nuitées jours
les agriculteurs
je sais ce qu'est l'agriculture l'ancien
modèle dont vous parlez il est
nécessaire tout comme le nouveau modèle
vous
voulait sans doute évoquer l'agriculture
biologique qui est une niche
elle permet une valeur ajoutée
supplémentaire des produits agricoles
tout simplement parce que c'est une
niche mais n'y a aucune
si je puis dire revues à comité de
lecture chercheur doit savoir ce à quoi
je fais allusion qui permet de dire
qu'il y à un plus en matière de santé
sur des produits si je puis dire issus
de l'agriculture biologique
ils ont des qualités organoleptiques
différentes que je préfère comme
beaucoup de nos concitoyens de
consommateurs il n'y a pas à pas des
vrais du bio sur la santé c'est ce que
n'ont aucune rejugé un comité le
président de république et quand même
fait cette annonce dans le premier
département bio de france dans la drôme
oui oui bah c'est quand même je suis
juste à côté de l'isère je connais bien
la drôme
donc je peux vous dire que c'est une
vraie réussite et que l'agriculture
justement on en a parlé encore une étude
sur le nombre de suicides sur la
difficulté des agriculteurs actuellement
quel est le secteur en agriculture qui
créent de l'emploi l'agriculture bio et
je veux dire c'est exponentiel
donc il faut arrêter encore une fois
soyons réalistes soyons pragmatiques
regardant les choses nous avons et
passons à l'action nous les repasser à
l'action c'est d'arrêter force la
galerie fusion de ces produits est
d'aller vers une agriculture qui créent
des emplois et c'est ça qui est
important et c'est ça qui attend les
agriculteurs du département de la manche
premier département agricole regard du
nombre d'agriculteurs
je connais très bien le département de
la drôme qui est un département qui fait
de la du bio qui en fait bien mais tout
le monde ne peut pas faire du bio tout
le monde ne peut pas faire grand bruit
court mais de dénigrer les agriculteurs
palais moi je suis persuadé et c'est
tout ça que les électeurs qui
connaissent leur métier mais ils veulent
retrouver les vraies valeurs du paysan
et ben je suis persuadé qu'ils veulent
aller vers ça qu'on y arrivera
quotidien si vous pensez monsieur le
sénateur convaincre la mois dans mères
de famille au père de famille qu'on
nourrissons les enfants nos enfants de
produits bourrés de produits chimiques
et pour la santé de leurs enfants mais
que ça ces produits chimiques sont non
son tabouret ya une autre question il ya
fait mieux c'est de dire que votre
morceau de jambon est équivalent un bol
de glyphosate
c'est ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure en disant que ce n'était pas
plus dangereux je suis désolé regardons
un agriculteur franchement mal à se
diffuser dans son champ il est
heureusement pour lui protégé le débat
autour de l'agriculture et tout si un
débat citoyen autour de l'alimentation
et moi je trouve qu'on donne beaucoup
d'espacé beaucoup de place ou lobby qui
défendent ce vieux modèles qui ont des
relais très importants dont ceux bien
roulé de faire dans tous les secteurs
il faudrait qu'on donne la parole aux
citoyens qu'on donne la parole français
français ça fait quelques années le
sujet les jaunes si on signe gilles et
de la citoyenneté au quotidien et de la
place que les citoyens ont dans la prise
de décision publique il faut pas
l'oublier
on a un modèle on a un modèle agricole a
changé je suis d'accord on doit aller
vers la grc au logis on doit aller vers
le bio c'est évident pour le côté santé
publique mais aussi pour le côté
biodiversité on oublie trop souvent on
se focalise sur nous en tant qu'humain
et pour l'emploi on oublie pour l'emploi
aussi c'est vrai mais donc on doit y
aller les 80 % de perte des insectes
c'est lié principalement à l'impact
agricole faut quand même aussi le
rappeler mais mais absolument pas si
vous voulez l'agriculture c'est la
partie des conventionnels l'écrit
culture conventionnelle n'est pas une
agriculture qui détruit la biodiversité
bien sûr que non si bien de l'armee vue
mais non combien parmi vous fréquentez
le monde agricole lid
voilà moi je vous demande d'aller nous
devons faire ce débat
si vous vous entendre sur les propos de
françois de rugy sur le nucléaire un
guillaume vont tard puisque ça fait
aussi partie des interrogations sur les
ambitions du gouvernement
ministre de l'écologie un qui elle se
montre un petit peu moins critique sur
cette filière pour lui et bien il a
salué l'important sein de la filière
nucléaire là aussi on assiste à un
nouveau roman tard on n'est pas encore
un recul un recul presse est vrai qu
effectivement on recule encore sur le
fair plus en plus c'était vraiment une
transition pour diminuer la part la part
du nucléaire parce que tout le monde
sait qu'on pourra pas arrêté d'un coup
le nucléaire alors on nous présente le
nucléaire comme l'énergie fabuleuse
parce qu'elle n'aimait pas de de carbone
est une chose par contre on a un petit
problème quand même sur les déchets sur
les accidents et je suis allé à bure
il n'y a pas très il ya pas très
longtemps visiter le le le projet de
centre d'enfouissement je peux vous dire
que ça pose quand même et pose vraiment
question de ce qu'on est en train de
faire quoi de faire du centre de la
terre une vraie poubelle qu'on laissera
à nos enfants petits-enfants puisqu'on
parle de 100 mille cent mille ans de
déchets qui seront enfouis comme ça je
pense qu'une vraie question est encore
une fois il faut être juste pragmatique
est passé sur des énergies renouvelables
afin de là je comprends pas pourquoi
vous parlez drones en chemin on a une
ppe
alors rien renoncement par rapport au
désir pour l'instant on n'en parle plus
il fallait il est en cours de discussion
et il me semble même qu'il est sorti
enfin bon là je parle sous votre
responsabilité côté politique côté côté
nucléaire c'est vrai que j'ai été très
anti nucléaire avec le problème du co2
on a vu qu'il y avait d'autres priorités
les priorités actuelles c'est le co2 il
faut pas oublier que l'une clair on doit
sortir je comprends pas pourquoi vous
parlez de renoncement il ya un
renoncement par rapport aux décisions
qui ont été prises par rapport au
précédent gouvernement qui ont été quand
même complètement parce que les propos
de françois de rugy contre as quand même
par rapport à ses positions passées car
oui d'accord lui à titre personnel il a
peut-être changé par rapport à la
politique du gouvernement
depuis 18 mois qui les luges
pas de renoncements jean bizet ensuite
le monial en ce qui concerne le
nucléaire si vous voulez il n'y a pas
une énergie aujourd'hui plus vertueuse
regard de 2,2 l'an de l'environnement au
travers des émissions de co2 vous l'avez
dit c'est vrai qu'il ya un problème du
déchet mais les déchets d'aujourd'hui
petit problème
oui non mais un gros problème graubmann
les déchets d'aujourd'hui peuvent être
si je puis dire les matières je dirais
noble de demain au travers des progrès
qui sont en train d'être réalisé et de
toute façon si l'union européenne a
investi autant d'argent
au delà même des 27-28 pour sur le
projet iter
c'est de passer à une autre une autre
échelle de façon à gommer ce problème
des déchets rapidement mais je vois pas
don aux managers et protéger
l'environnement sont d abord sur
françois de rugy
moi j'ai envie de dire que l'on buisson
le pouvoir rend amnésique et aveugle moi
j'ai connu et fréquenté ça dans why on a
milité dans le mail art ni irriter je
vous avoue que je comprends pas la
difficulté qu'on a avec le nucléaire
c'est un nos centrales sont
vieillissantes
on sait pas gérer les déchets est en
réalité ça coûte très cher aux pouvoirs
publics et donc en françaises et aux
français et la vraie difficulté c'est
tant qu'on n'a pas activé la sortie du
nucléaire on ne développe pas lésiné
jean loup on nous voilà un exemple 4000
éoliennes offshore en europe une en
france on a la façade maritime la plus
grande d'europe et donc vous voyez bien
qu'ils aient acquis un sujet c'est que
pour réduire la part du nucléaire on a
besoin le volant des bolides y entame on
a besoin d'un bon courage et l'énergie
remercie merci à tous les quatre on va
continuer justement de s'intéresser à
l'actualité parlementaire on retourne
dans l'hémicycle nous attend et xandre
poussa on a parlé de la loi pacte il ya
aussi la séance des questions
d'actualité qui aura lieu maintenant
dans une vingtaine de minutes alexandre
sur la loi pas que vous souhaitiez nous
faire un point justement sur ce qu'il va
être examiné cet après midi oui des
films durant cette séance de questions
d'actualité
on va parler des lanceurs de balles de
défense qui sont utilisés par les
policiers lors des manifestations
gilet jaune alors quelques chiffres ces
flash ball ont été utilisés plus de neuf
mille fois depuis le mois de novembre
ils ont fait plus de 300 blessés et
actuellement le conseil d'état est en
train d'examiner une éventuelle
interdiction de ces lanceurs de balles
de défense pour les prochaines
manifestations et puis dans cette séance
les sénateurs vont évoquer également la
protection de l'enfance puisqu'un
nouveau secrétariat d'état chargé de
cette question a été créée cette semaine
suite à un magazine d'investigation
diffusée par la chaîne france 3 sur les
enfants placés comme quoi la télé peut
faire bouger les lignes
et enfin il y aura une question sur la
taxation des géants du numérique qui est
jugée trop faible par certains sénateurs
de gauche
et puis une autre question sur la
réforme de la justice de nicole
belloubet qui est actuellement un peu
dans l'impasse
face à la grogne des professionnels du
droit merci beaucoup alexandre pour
toutes vos précisions ont continué les
réactions avec vous êtes en train mais
avec le sénateur l air de paris philippe
dominati
oui philippe dominati nous allons parler
ensemble tout d'abord du projet de loi
pacte un projet de loi qui ne vous
convainc pas vraiment notamment sur le
volet des privatisations
que répondez-vous au gouvernement qui
juge et bien que la droite a une
attitude contradictoire sur ce sujet il
n'y a pas d'études contradictoires moi
je suis un libéral
et là il s'agit de céder les bénéfices
d'un monopole qui restera un monopole
est une entreprise privée dans des
conditions pour le moins curieuse et
donc effectivement jeu plus et la
française des jeux c'est à des pc ja des
pères incontestablement adp parce que il
ya plusieurs problématiques qui se
chevauchent concernant adp d'avoir la
valorisation le gouvernement ne donne
aucun prix ne donne pas le but à
atteindre
deuxièmement on a le sentiment que le
match est joué d'avancé
c'est une longue histoire que les
parisiens et les franciliens connaissent
bien qui concerne des infrastructures de
transport même une situation peut être
préjudiciable pour un libéral je dirais
d'avoir des positions dominantes dans un
secteur c'est toujours gênant et donc
c'est un dossier complexe et le
gouvernement a voulu le passé d'une
manière
discrète dans cette loi pâte notamment
l'assemblée nationale où il y avait très
peu de parlementaires en séance et la
force du sénat c'est de mettre en
lumière cette intention vous n'êtes pas
convaincus par les garanties apportées
par le rapporteur jean françois husson
qui demandaient des outils de régulation
pour vous c'est insuffisant ou en saas
et technique
d'abord il ya une question de principe
est ce qu'on considère qu'on est
d'accord pour cette privatisation
c'est vrai qu'en général l'état est
plutôt un mauvais actionnaires qui des
formats de ses intérêts en l'occurrence
dans ce dossier il les défend très mal
sur la valorisation d'entreprise est en
réalité c'est un cadeau et nous nous ne
voulons pas d'un cadeau après l'échec de
ce qui s'est passé lors des rotations
des autoroutes le sénat également
avant-hier relever les seuils sociaux
avec le projet de la pac notamment de 50
à 100 salariés
est ce que ce n'est pas un nouveau coup
de rabot aux droits des salariés
non c'est dans la loi pas qu'il ya des
bonnes choses parce qu'il faut
effectivement simplifier la vie des
entreprises puisque notre économie
dépend essentiellement des entreprises
et il ya un certain nombre de mesures
qui vont dans le bon sens
effectivement il faut libérer un peu les
entrepreneurs un mot enfin sur une
question d'actualité un vous connaissez
bien les équipements des forces de
police ça va être un sujet ans qui va
être au coeur des questions d'actualité
d'ici une demi-heure
faut-il renoncer pour vous au lanceur de
balles de défense dont la dangerosité
est pointé du doigt
et alors que l'on apprend qu'il ya bien
eu un tir le week-end dernier dans bien
les blessures à de jérôme rodriguez
il faut pour nos forces de l'ordre une
arme intermédiaire et donc on peut
remplacer si on trouve une arme plus
performante mais qui correspondent à la
mission et à la protection de nos forces
de l'ordre on ne peut pas laisser de nos
forces de l'ordre sans aucune protection
ou comme sulte hymne production d'armes
à feu il faut une arme intermédiaire et
danseurs sont ils à des spécialistes ont
considéré que c'était la bonne arme
peut-être qu'il faut en trouver une plus
performantes ou une meilleure pour
qu'effectivement on évite un certain
nombre de bassy dans dans l'utilisation
de larmes
eh bien merci à beaucoup philippe
dominati d'avoir répondu à mes questions
contact avec les remercie beaucoup pour
cette nouvelle
action comment se décline le grand débat
sur le terrain depuis le lancement de la
grande concertation nationale voulu par
l'exécutif
les réunions publiques se multiplient
c'est le cas dans l'oise où nous sommes
rendus hier soir sur dans cette terre
d'élection
le sénateur et leur jérôme à chiens et
vous allez le voir la colère à des gilet
jaune n'est pas encore retombée c'est un
reportage de jonathan du ps comme un
village d'irréductibles à l'entrée de
senlis ce rond point les gilet jaune de
l'oise l'occupent depuis la mi novembre
ici une dizaine de chômeurs artisans ou
employés se côtoient chaque jour
la mobilisation ne faiblit pas on est
pacifiste il ya des actions qui se fond
à droite à gauche mais
oui mon registre petite visite aux
traversy ce jour là le sénateur de
l'oise
jérôme bascher seront sur place c'est la
deuxième fois qu'il rencontre ses gilet
jaune depuis le début de la crise c'est
courageux là parce qu' avec la neige ce
matin je suis passé j'ai vu vous étiez
là ce matin j'ai dit vous êtes courageux
sur le rond point le pouvoir d'achat
monopolise les débats
l'élu est rapidement interrogé sur le
prix d'une d'or et de la vie quotidienne
reprenait très vite ce niveau le
producteur a340 aujourd'hui les
discussions se poursuivent sur tous les
sujets emmanuel macron les violences
policières ou encore le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne
après une heure des changes jérôme
bascher livre ses impressions à chaud
ceux qui sont là sur le rond point c'est
clairement la france qu'on entend pas
d'habitude celle qu'on voit pas
d'habitude dit dans les bureaux de vote
ni à faire leurs courses au niveau
politique
donc ces gens qui veulent être entendus
pour être entendu les habitants de
senlis et des alentours ont été invités
à participer à la première réunion
publique dans le cadre du grand débat
quatre ateliers au programme sur les
grands thèmes proposés par le président
ici l'atelier fiscalité dépenses
publiques
on est toujours en perte de vitesse dans
nos finances
dans une autre salle la maire de senlis
modère le débat sur l'organisation de
l'état souvent soit en parlez-vous
trottoirs et des problèmes de la vitesse
dans les rues soit on parle d'un projet
particulier
mais on ne se réunit pas pour parler de
de la démocratie en fait une soixantaine
de personnes a participé à cette
première réunion
la mairie de senlis a prévu d'en
organiser deux autres du même type
voilà et on va en parler avec mes
invités sur ce plateau jérôme durain
bonjour mais d'être sur ce plateau vous
êtes sénateur socialiste également avec
nous et sébastien meurant vous êtes
sénateur l ère du val d'oise et puis
vincent delahaye vous êtes sénateur
centriste de l'essonne le merci à l'âge
où les trois jours durant
c'est un succès quand même ce grand
débat national on voit chaque commune
chaque département s'empare de cette
initiative voulue par emmanuel macron
pour organiser des réunions publiques
les maires qui était un petit peu
réticent à se sont emparés de ce débat
et on voit ça fonctionne c'est un la
démocratie qui vise tout simplement
il ya dans le mouvement des jeunes de
choses centrale me semble-t-il c'est une
crise sociale une aspiration sociale et
un investissement démocratique une
réappropriation du débat politique par
des gens qui ont été parfois plus ou
moins éloignées et non je pense à des
ouvrages et les choses en revanche le
grand débat et l évidence utile c'est un
débat utile il faut qu'ils aient lieu
les gens ils sont donc il faut y être
après faut pas être naïf sur les
conditions de son organisation et sur
les choix qui présida aux thèmes qui
sont évoqués les lignes rouges fixées
par le gouvernement lire c'est par
exemple et des questions qui sont quand
même très orienté donc soyons pas naïfs
s'affranchissait ligne libre dans ces
débats ses rangs heureusement oui
heureusement que la parole est libre
alors seuil et la démocratie à ces
cycles de six que ça s'appelle les
élections donc l'impression de revivre
des élections présidentielles sauf que
ce qu'on attend d'un président c'est
qu'il préside en est là aujourd'hui un
candidat qui est en campagne
et qu'est ce qui va sortir de tout cela
parce que la politique c'est faire des
choix et là on est encore dans la
communication à la communication c'est
très bien mais il ya 230 ans début
février commençaient les fameux qe2 les
ans et ça s'est mal terminée donc après
c'est c'est parole libérée qu'est ce qui
va en sortir
concrètement sur le pouvoir d'achat sur
l'immigration sans réforme des
institutions sur l'efficacité de la
dépense publique
j'ai les plus grandes craintes parce que
depuis 18 mois et nous qui sommes en
finance voyons que les défis scruggs se
creuse que la taxe augmente et qu'il n'y
a pas de ligne politique et qui le
gouvernement ne sait pas où il va et ça
c'est grave
forcément des déçus à l'issue de ce
grand débat ben moi je pense que la
démocratie c'est le débat permanent donc
là vous dites c'est une réussite
il ya quand même les départements où il
ya aucun des barques asie
qui sont organisés on n'en parle pas
beaucoup quand on regarde sur senlis
alors vous avez d'une soixantaine de
personnes mais donne dans la salle on
n'avait pas l'impression qu'ils avaient
une soixantaine de personnes et pour une
ville comme soliste s'est pas beaucoup
donc moi je relativise ray un petit peu
le succès bon le président a souhaité
avoir cette période de deux mois pendant
laquelle on discute
je pense que c'est bien à un moment
donné il faut aussi tranché le président
est là pour gouverner effectivement pour
présider mais avec le gouvernement il
doit prendre des décisions
je sais pas je sais pas comment il va
sortir de ce débat parce que honnêtement
il va falloir quand même quelques
dispositions assez forte pour répondre à
l'attenté qui leur a suscité donc c'est
compliqué pour moi pour moi c'est une
situation compliquée je pense que le
gouvernement serait bien inspiré mais
comme sur beaucoup de sujets de
l'écouter un petit peu plus au sénat les
réunions et bien ont lieu mais pour
autant la colère un défilé jaune que ce
soit tous les samedis lors des
manifestations ou encore aux dans les
ronds-points elles sont toujours
présents ça ne décolère pas oui c'est
frdj les jaunes c'est pas un clapotis
c'est une vague extrêmement forte et les
gilet jaune ne sont peut-être plus sur
les ronds points mais ils sont encore
dans les têtes
et attention attention à ce que
l'exécutif et présidera publics ne
prennent pas le relatif succès du débat
et de ses performances
on connaît le talent du président pour
un solde de tout compte
parce que les questions qui ne seront
pas réglés sincèrement si les
propositions sont pas à la hauteur elles
vont revenir avec d'autant plus de
violence que les gens sont une forme de
colère donc effectivement à court terme
sa part être un dispositif intéressant
et les limites qui avait été indiqué
mais je crois qu'il faut il faut il faut
entendre que les questions sociales
fiscales institutionnels elles doivent
trouver des réponses concrètes et il
s'agit pas de faire du populisme à bon
compte sur dos par exemple du sénat ça a
été dit ou chaudes les institutions
parce que sur les institutions vrai
sujet c'est quand même la place de
l'exécutif par rapport au parlement
et ça j'aimerais qu'on en parle un peu
sébastien meurant cette colère elle
continue elle se traduit un toujours de
façon assez visible tous les samedis
disaient les gilet jaune qui manifestent
ils sont un peu moins nombreux mais la
violence est de plus en plus importante
or je ne dirais pas que la violence est
plus importante la violence les casseurs
sont identifiés la part du temps la
police les connaît on les élus locaux
connaissent leur propre voyous moi je
connais des jeunes qui continue parce
que il on trouvait aussi sur les
ronds-points de la fraternité des
échanges mais ce que je vais vous dire
moi c'est que sur mon territoire et il
n'y a pas de demande de grands débats
pourquoi parce que la parole est libre
que le maire reçoit sans permanence
laisse plusieurs fois par mois qu'il y à
des réunions de quartiers où les
réunions sont ouvertes
évidemment à n'importe quelle question
où les élus s'efforcent de répondre à
ces questions
et moi je m'étonne que ce grand débat la
façon dont ça a été initié nous avons
une autorité indépendante qui étaient
chargés normalement de mettre en place
ce grand débat et qui a refusé et je
citais tout à l'heure avec une ancienne
sénatrice qui a refusé de s'en occuper
à quoi sert ces autorités indépendantes
et il y à un article d'un dans un
journal bien connus ou ce grand débat
peut-être que les questions ont été
pauvres on être posé toutes natures mais
les réponses sont déjà écrites par le
président de la république
et ça je vous renvoie vers cet article
vous entendre sur la question ce qu'on
avait des ailes lbd les lanceurs de
balles de défense il y aura une question
de votre collègue socialiste dans un
instant la question se pose de leur
interdiction dans les manifestations moi
je ne pense pas que se pose parce que
honnêtement qu'est ce que par quoi on va
la remplacer
comment ça va se passer et comment
comment les forces de l'ordre peuvent
intervenir parce que les manifestations
sont souvent calme mais elles sont pas
toujours calme et il ya quand même des
excès qui soient insupportables et aussi
il faut protéger nos forces de l'ordre
donc moi je vois pas beaucoup
d'alternative je dis pas que c'est
parfait j'étais pas qu'elles sont
utilisées toujours parfaitement mais je
vois pas beaucoup d'alternatives est
allé aujourd'hui désarmé nos forces de
l'ordre je pense que ce serait une très
mauvaise décision
donc moi je suis plutôt pour le statu
quo jean durand sur ce point on voit
qu'il ya quand même
des blessés ils sont d'ailleurs en tête
des manifestations ce samedi c'est une
question qui va continuer de s'inviter
dans le débat public c'est une question
extrêmement importante
tous les défenseurs des libertés
publiques sont inquiets le défenseur des
droits dans le plan au plan national le
conseil de l'europe
les médias qui sont eux mêmes visées se
pose beaucoup de questions il y a un
vrai problème de doctrine d'emploi des
forces de l'ordre
moi j'avais interpellé le ministre
castaner sur les grenades de
désencerclement nantes on sait qu'elles
sont dangereuses dangereuse pardon les
jets livre iv les le bd c'est la même
chose et on sort de balle le concepteur
le constructeur de ces armes dit
lui-même qu'elles sont mal utilisés donc
il ya des démarches européenne pour
viser à une désescalade dans l'emploi de
la force et la france est absente
il ya une dérive qui est dangereuse et
je pense qu'il faut mettre ça en lien
avec la loi anti-casseurs contre
laquelle je me suis battu et il y à là
quelque chose qui doit tous nous alerter
principe de cette émission on tourne
salle des conférences où se trouve le
thème traduit avec le sénateur gérard
longuet puisque mediapart un ce site
d'information vient de faire de
nouvelles révélations dans la sphère
benalla cette boutade oui nous en
parlerons dans un instant avec un autre
invité mais avec gérard longuet je
voudrais parler d'abord il vient du
cumul des mandats alors qu'il ya une
volonté de l'exécutif d'assouplir et
bien ce cumul des mandats qu'en pensez
vous et bien de cette volonté notamment
pour les maires de petites villes
c'est une question de bon sens et il
faut que les parlementaires français
députés et sénateurs est une expérience
et qu'ils aient en même temps des
responsabilités et donc je suis pour le
retour au au cumul limiter ses dires un
poste national et un poste d'exécutif
local je ne vois d'ailleurs pas la
nécessité de mettre une barre c'est pas
une question d'emploi du temps c'est une
question de responsabilité les grandes
villes ont le droit d'accéder au
parlement comme les autres voilà donc
vous n'êtes pas pour un seuil par
exemple noura patriat propose est les
villes de moins de 2500 aller c'est une
façon pour lui de faire marche arrière
mais il faut aller carrément dans la
réalité l'arrêter c'est que la france a
besoin d'unité entre ceux qui votent la
loi et ceux qui la connaissent parce
qu'ils la mettent en oeuvre sur le
terrain est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
un débat opportun à rouvrir alors qu'on
le sait la question du cumul est très
impopulaire chez les français je vais
vous dire on a ouvert la porte du débat
public
il faut ça va être le concours lépine
des solutions alors il ya des gens qui
sont yakafokon et puis tu sais et puis
ceux qui ont un peu d'expérience qui
profitent de ce débat pour faire
bénéficier les autres des leçons de
l'histoire pratique est ce que pour vous
il faudra que est liée à non cumul des
indemnités s'ils ont rétabli ce cumul
je vais vous dire c'est absolument un
détail car contrairement à ce que des
certains sur les ronds points
si on veut des hommes et des femmes
politiques de qualité il faut qu'ils
aient le salaire d'un cadre supérieur
cela vaut ce prix là le démocratie a un
prix et le succès 1 coûte à notre sujet
sur lesquelles l'exécutif ne semble pas
pour le coup reculé c'est le non cumul
dans le temps vous y êtes toujours
farouchement opposée gérard longuet eh
ben je chauffe a opposé mais c'est aux
électeurs de choisir si les électeurs
estiment qu'ils sont bien représentés
pourquoi diable leur imposer quelqu'un
d'autre juste une dernière question à
l'ancien ministre de la défense
quel sens faut-il pour vous réserver aux
jihadistes français incarcérés dans le
nord-est de la syrie alors que les
militaires américains s'apprêtent à
quitter la zone
il ya certains députés notamment les
républicains qui veulent des assassinats
ciblés
je crois que la vérité c'est que
quelqu'un qui a commis un crime ou un
délit et ces djihadistes ont commis des
crimes et des délits doivent être jugés
sur place c'est-à-dire en syrie est jugé
et condamné exécuté leur peine
j'ajoute que je ne souhaite pas du tout
leur retour parce que je considère que
quand on porte les armes contre ce pays
contre son pays
on perd la nationalité de notre pays eh
bien merci beaucoup gérard longuet
d'avoir répondu à mes questions
merci thème pour cette réaction je vous
parle alors moi je vais aller voir le
fabricant de sel bd prochainement moi je
pense qu'il faut pas dirigera désormais
les forces de l'ordre qui sont agressés
qui soudent ont leur vie est menacée par
contre il ne faut pas mettre ces
doctrines d'emploi moi je vous
rejoindrai volontiers puisque là mon
avis c'est la doctrine d'emploi qui pose
problème
les tensions qui peuvent amener à mal
utilisé ces armes et surtout c'est que
le problème c'est la procédure pénale
pour moi on ne peut pas mettre des
braves gens qui manifestent paisiblement
et les casseurs il faut
interpellés les casseurs les séparer les
braves gens et les punir les black blocs
ont été saccagés nantes rennes qui sont
venus saccager l'arc de triomphe
comment se fait-il que le gouvernement
et les fonctionnaires qui était
responsable sécurité n'ait pas été
sanctionné
l'arc de triomphe sont saccagés la tombe
du soldat inconnu c'est un drame
aujourd'hui quels sont les responsables
n'y en a pas et le drame de sas et qui a
pas responsables et moi j'ai été choqué
de voir des petites mamies ou des des
jeunes perdre un oeil
et je considère que c'est quand même
très mal or il ya beaucoup de blessés et
qu'il faut absolument remettre en cause
la doctrine d'emploi mais par contre
avec les ceux qui tirent sur les forces
de l'ordre comme on l'a vu ou qui
prennent des armes pour blesser ou
gravement ou assassinés forces de
l'ordre il faut que les forces de
l'ordre puissent se défendre il a une
proposition aux mains des sénateurs
communistes qui sera examiné au mois de
mars
justement qui propose l'interdiction des
flashball vous pourriez la soutenir on
s'engueulait non non non je crois que ce
que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
montrent que je soutiendrai pas et
honnêtement honnêtement on a été maire
les uns et les autres même si on parle
de revenir sur le cumul le non-cumul
mais on a des polices municipales moi
j'ai d'une police ne suis pas qu'à des
flashball et ils les utilisent de façon
très parcimonieuse et vraiment quasiment
jamais donc dans la réalité on n'a pas
besoin comme de rassurer ses personnels
parce que ils font un job qui est pas
facile donc c'est pas évident de
toujours garder son calme et et d'être
en retenue par rapport à des gens qui
sont parfois agressifs et donc il faut
quand même leur donner des moyens de se
défendre
lorsqu'ils sont provoqués ou attaquer
jérôme durain sur cette question aussi
qui sera abordé lors de la séance des
questions d'actualité 1 c'est le retour
des djihadistes on sait que il ya débat
au sein du gouvernement sur leur retour
est ce que doivent revenir en france
est ce que c'est à l'état français de
les juger sur des profils extrêmement
dangereux dans une zone extrêmement
troublée avec des interlocuteurs
pour qui la relation avec la france
n'est pas forcément évidente naturel
donc laissé
ces personnes dans des conditions de
jugement et des tensions qui ne sont pas
totalement stabilisée
là bas me paraît dangereux pour nous qu
reviendront-ils dans quelles conditions
avec elle contrôle le rapatriement et la
possibilité de les juger ici me paraît
moins incertaine je suis un budget a dit
c'est un djihadiste morts voilà c'est
dit
d'autre part les prisons sont pleines
moi j'ai visité une prison mois de
septembre il ya un quartier pour les
islamistes
est-ce que c'est aux français de nourrir
de protéger de sauver les vies de ces
créatures qui ont assassiné égorgé et on
sait très bien qu'ils ont à être jugé
sur place hélas le ministre de la
défense disait les choses que je viens
de dire de manière un peu plus avec
quelques féminisme et bien qu'il soit
jugé sur place et ce n'est qu'ils soient
déchus de leur nationalité et surtout
pas alors sinon ça en vient à la
question des frontières que c'est les
individus dangereux puissent être
déchues connaît plus rien à voir avec
eux ils ont pris les armes contre la
france ils ont pris les armes et ont
commis des actes de guerre enfin si les
enfants ces autres sujets ça se passe
pas comme ça mais les parents sont
responsables et les français n'ont pas à
assumer les conséquences des actes de
ces monstres je le dirai de façon plus
mesurée mais je pense moi qui doivent
être jugés sur place sauf effectivement
les enfants mais c'est vrai qu'ils ont
ils ont porté les armes contre la france
c'est vrai que c'est un c'est super
grave il n'ya pas y'a pas de fait plus
grave que ce que celui là donc pour moi
ça ça mérite effectivement à un jugement
sur place
je vois pas la nécessité de les
rapatrier eh bien merci merci à toute la
séance de questions d'actualité va
bientôt débuter
avant cela une nouvelle règle sont avec
vous au tam traduit vous êtes avec
françois noël buffet sénateur et l'air
du rhône puisque je le disais il ya de
nouvelles révélations par le site
d'information mediapart dans l affaire
pénale
oui on apprend notamment qu'alexandre
benalla tout d'abord a été impliqué dans
les contrats avec un oligarque russe
alors qu'il travaillait à l'elysée
contrairement à ce qu'il a dit devant la
commission denquête j'ajoute que vincent
kra d'alexandre benalla se sont vu le 26
juillet en violation du contrôle
judiciaire et qu'enfin et bien alexandre
robin et là aurait eu donc
avec l'elysée alors même qu'ils étaient
mises en examen votre réaction à toutes
ces révélations
moi je trouve ça d'abord pitoyable mais
en même temps je ne suis pas surpris
monsieur benalla et l'entourage général
ne cesse de mentir de cacher la vérité
il faut que ce soit la presse qui petit
à petit certes les éléments je pense que
nous ne sommes pas au bout du système et
qui leur a sans doute encore d'autres
révélations
en tous les cas ce qui apparaît sous
réserve que tout cela soit et vérifié
évidemment ils nous vont de la prendre
mais ce qui apparaît c'est que il est on
ne peut pas lui faire confiance à aucun
moment ce qui jette le doute évidemment
sur l'ensemble de ses déclarations et
sur l'ensemble de la situation
donc il ya un moment il fait partie
peut-être falloir passer la vitesse
supérieure pour qu'on sache réellement
quelle est la situation que la nature de
ses liens
quel est son rôle actuel at il toujours
un rôle actuellement en tous les cas ce
qu'il dit lui-même montre à l'évidence
qu'il a toujours un rôle avec l'elysée
au sens large
je ne pourrais pas me permettre de dire
et qui en particulier la commission d
enquête parlementaire n'était elle pas
dans l'incapacité de trouver la vérité
lorsque l'on voyait bien la quantité de
contradictions voire de mensonges et de
parjure peut-être qu'il y a eu devant la
commission d'enquêté parlementaire n'est
pas un juge d'instruction
donc elle ne fonctionne que sur des
auditions et en fonction de ses qualités
en prêter serment
mais oui bien sûr dont il a menti c'est
un parjure permanent donc évidemment
qu'on peut pas avoir confiance et que ça
crée le doute plus que le doute
sauf que notre mission s'est arrêté donc
il en revient maintenant à la justice de
saisir la justice et qu'elle justice
fasse son travail avec autant de
célérité qu'elle l'a fait dans les
époques rations qui lui sont interdites
donc saisir la justice sur tout ses
parjures à titre personnel je suis tout
à fait favorable oui eh bien merci
beaucoup françois noël buffet pour
d'autres rives action à ces dernières
révélations de la sphère abena là et on
va tout de suite rejoindre alexandre
poussard pour le programme de cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
très vite âme durant cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement eh
bien on va parler des lanceurs de balles
de défense qui sont beaucoup utilisés
par les policiers pendant les
manifestations des gilet jaune et qui
font beaucoup de dégâts avec quelques
chiffres ces lanceurs de balles de
défense ont été utilisés plus de neuf
mille fois depuis le début du mois de
novembre et ils ont fait plus de 300
blessées lors de ces manifestations
alors beaucoup demandent son
interdiction cette interdiction est
actuellement à l'étude par le conseil
d'état trois recours sont également
examinées 1 pour suspendre l'utilisation
de ces armes non létales pour les
prochaines manifestations des gilet
jaune durant le 5 février et le 12
février
mais pour le ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner les abus de certains
policiers doit faire l'objet d' enquêtes
pénales et ne doivent pas justifier la
suppression totale des lanceurs de
balles de défense
et puis durant cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement on va
également parlé la protection de
l'enfance avec le nouveau secrétariat
d'état qui a été créé cette semaine on
parlera également de la taxation des
géants du numérique jugé trop faible par
par certains sénateurs de gauche
et puis aussi de la réforme de la
justice qui est un peu dans l'impasse
la clause vient de sonner c'est le début
des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
et si on d'actualité au gouvernement de
se retransmis en direct sur public sénat
sur d'autres sites et sur facebook
chacun sera attentif je le répète à
chaque fois au respect des uns et des
autres et à son temps ce que plus
prosaïque mais qui est aussi important
mais je ne voudrais pas commencé sans
félicité et salué le nouveau secrétaire
d'état en charge de la protection de
l'enfance auprès du ministre de la soul
et de santé des solidarités avec qui je
viens de m'entretenir
on lui souhaite le meilleur sur un sujet
très sensible et important
la parole est à notre collègue gilbert
roger pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain sur le sénateur
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre ma question s'adresse à
monsieur laurent nunes aise
monsieur le ministre je tiens tout
d'abord à en préambule à ma question a
condamné fermement toutes les violences
commises à l'égard des forces de l'ordre
qui ont émaillé certaines des
manifestations des filets jaunes depuis
le mois de novembre
la condamnation de ces agissements ne
peut cependant faire oublier le grand
nombre de manifestants blessés par les
lanceurs de balles de défense lbd près
d'une centaine de blessés graves ont été
recensées en grande majorité par les
tirs de ces engins dont 17 ont perdu un
oeil depuis le début de la contestation
depuis 2009 le lbd40 a remplacé le
flash-ball super pro dans les opérations
de maintien de l'ordre car plus puissant
plus précis en théorie son usage est
très encadrée le tireur doit viser de
façon privilégiée le torse
ainsi que les membres supérieurs ou
inférieurs mais en aucun cas la tête
pour rappel la france en terme de
maintien de l'ordre fait figure
d'exception
elle est le seul pays européen utilisé
des grenades explosives
l'un des rares avec la grèce l'espagne
et la pologne à faire usage de l bd
votre ministère a lancé le 23 décembre
dernier un appel d'offres pour
l'acquisition de 1280 nouveau lbd
l'emploi de tir duel bd a été massif
depuis le début des mouvements des
filets jaunes par des effectifs en civil
non spécialistes des manifestations et
de l' usage de ses armes dites
intermédiaires
l'année dernière le défenseur des droits
à votre question
monsieur jacques toubon dans un rapport
pro pardon préconise l interdiction de l
usage du lbd ma question est donc la
suivante monsieur le ministre
devant l'insuffisance de formation des à
la doctrine d'emploi de ces armes par
les forces de l'ordre et l'efficacité
contestée du dispositif de caméra
remettons le gouvernement compte-t-il
suivre l'avis du défenseur des droits en
interdisant l'usagé de ces armes
la réponse est au secrétaire d'état
auprès de l'humour de l'intérieur que
laurent neige
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur roger d'abord merci du soutien
que vous venez d'apporter aux forces de
l'ordre vous en remercie vivement
concernant l' usage du nbd d'abord vous
rappeler monsieur le sénateur que tous
les samedis maintenant nous avons un
rendez-vous le cadre du mouvement dit de
gilet jaune où il ya des manifestations
de voie publique qui sont organisées
partout en france à paris comme vous le
savez et puis à hyères en province
chaque samedi nous assistons au même
scène où un certain nombre d'individus
très violent des casseurs se mêlent aux
manifestations et les fonds dégénéré
parfois au début
souvent à la fin et c'était encore le
cas samedi dernier sur la place de la
bastille sont des casseurs extrêmement
violent qui pis qui s'en prennent aux
forces de l'ordre qui quand ils le
peuvent s'en prennent à nos institutions
c'est à dire aux mairies aux préfectures
au sous-préfecture de manière
extrêmement violente et pardon mais on
peut parfois difficilement qualifier ça
de gestion de maintien de l'ordre public
ce à quoi ce à quoi à part dont sont
confrontés nos forces de l'ordre
s'apparente beaucoup plus à des une
forme de guérilla urbaine et nos
effectifs interviennent à ce moment là
pour mettre fin à ces exactions pour
mettre fin à ces pillages pour mettre
fin à ces violences
et effectivement vous avez raison
monsieur le sénateur roger à ce
moment-là il utilise tout l'armement
intermédiaires qui est à leur
disposition pour éviter justement
d'utiliser un armement létale sans
lequel il ne pourrait se défendre sans
lesquels leur intégrité physique serait
menacée et il s'agit également de
protéger le reste des manifestants qui
ne demandent pas avoir ces casseurs et
c'est ce que nous faisons tous les
samedis alors oui le lb d utiliser
c'était encore le cas samedi dernier sur
la place de la bastille sur la place de
la république uniquement dans les
moments de grande tension et ce matériel
est utilisé je peux vous le confirmer
il est utilisé par un personnel qui est
habilité qui est formé à cette fin dans
un usage qui est proportionné qui est
contrôlé et quand il ya des fautes elles
sont sanctionnées
et quand il y a des suspicions de
violence il ya des investigations
judiciaires qui sont menées et c'est le
cas actuellement avec l'inspection
générale de la police nationale qui est
site qui est saisie d'un certain nombre
d'affaires mais devant vous je veux
d'abord qu'on danger
policiers blessés et penser au courage
et à la détermination de nos forces de
l'ordre qui tous les samedis font face
merci la parole est au président claude
malhuret
pour le groupe des indépendants
république et territoires monsieur le
président donne la parole monsieur le
premier ministre le venezuela possède
les plus grandes réserves mondiales de
pétrole et son peuple crève de faim le
dictateur de caracas emprisonne et
assassinent 100 morts ces jours derniers
600 prisonniers politiques régulièrement
torturé trois millions de réfugiés plus
de médicaments en revanche pour la
drogue pas de problème le plus grand
cartel de narcotrafiquants du monde est
supervisé par les militaires
vénézuéliens eux-mêmes deux hommes se
prétendent aujourd'hui président de la
république le castro de chavistes maduro
à l'issue d'une élection truquée dénoncé
dans le monde entier
erwan gaido élu lui démocratiquement
président de l'assemblée nationale
maduro ça n'étonnera personne est
soutenue par les pays ultra démocratique
que sont la russie la chine la turquie
et cuba l'iran et la corée du nord
il est aussi soutenu à fond en france
par le leader minimo de la france
soumise à cuba qui repère les dictateurs
qui repère les dictateurs avec un flair
infaillible le tyranneau fils mélenchon
qui dénonce les violences policières à
paris mais support sans trop de douleur
les centaines de morts à caracas
gaye 2 est reconnue par la
quasi-totalité des pays d'amérique
latine et au total par une vingtaine de
pays du monde
l'union européenne qui penche pour gaido
s'est contenté d'appeler par ce qu'elle
appelle un ultimatum à de nouvelles
élections
hélas maduro à rejeter immédiatement cet
ultimatum
ce qui n'a pour le moment entraîné
aucune réaction de l'europe un ultimatum
sans conséquence vous me l'accorderez
monsieur le premier ministre c'est
évidemment un peu fâché trois
journalistes espagnols et deux
journalistes français ont été arrêtés
hier à caracas
on est sans nouvelles d'eux l'espagne a
exigé publiquement la libération
immédiate de ces journalistes alors je
voudrais vous poser deux questions ce
premier ministre premièrement la france
et l'union européenne vont elles
reconnaître le président gazeau avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard et que la guerre
civile n'éclate au venezuela
deuxièmement le gouvernement compte-t-il
exigé publiquement la libération
immédiate des journalistes français et
avez-vous de leur nouvelle je vous
remercie
la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre et le
premier ministre monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président malgré vous
m'interrogez sur le venezuela a de quoi
parlons nous dans cette crise terrible
que des ce pays nous parlons d'un pays
qui est plongé depuis plus de trois ans
dans une crise sans précédent
un pays potentiellement riche qui
connaît aujourd'hui des situation de
près et famine une économie totalement
exemple une population dont nous savons
qu'elle est privée de médicaments et de
l'ensemble des biens de première
nécessité
parlons d'un pays qui a mis en place une
répression sanglante de ces oppositions
nous parlons d'un pays vous l'avez sites
est monsieur le président qui emprisonne
des journalistes étrangers deux
journalistes français ont été arrêtés
trois journalistes espagnols je me
permets de vous indiquer monsieur le
président malhuret que le ministre des
affaires étrangères et l'ensemble du
gouvernement a exigé la libération
immédiate de ces journalistes et de
leurs collègues et confrères espagnols
nous parlons aujourd'hui au venezuela
d'un président qui revendique un second
mandat présidentiel sur la base
d'élections qui se sont tenues en mai
2018 qui ne répondait de toute évidence
à aucune des conditions essentielles de
la démocratie aujourd'hui le venezuela
est à la croisée des chemins
depuis que le 23 janvier se sont tenues
des manifestations massives et que le
jour même le président de l'assemblée
nationale
wang wei d'eau a prêté serment comme
président par intérim du venezuela en
vue at-il affirmé
d'organiser des élections véritablement
démocratiques
notre responsabilité celle de la france
celle de l'union européenne c'est de
veiller au respect de la volonté du
peuple vénézuélien
c'est le sens de la déclaration du
président de la république qui le 26
janvier dernier a appelé à l' annonce
dans un délai de huit jours de la
convocation de nouvelles élections
à défaut monsieur le président nous
reconnaîtrons en pleine coordination
avec nos partenaires européens avec
l'allemagne
avec l'espagne avec le royaume-uni 3
ngaido comme président par intérim du
venezuela pour avancer en ce sens c'est
également monsieur le président c'est
également le sens de la création d'un
groupe de contact international proposé
par l'union européenne parce que nous
sommes convaincus que la seule solution
viable à cette crise est politique
négociée et pacifique avec la
coopération des organisations régionales
et des pays qui entourent le venezuela
le ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian est
aujourd'hui même à bucarest avec ses
homologues européens pour consolider et
affirmer cette position commune face à
la crise un mot peut-être sur la
situation humanitaire qui est
préoccupante
plus de 3 millions de vénézuéliens ont
quitté leur pays et l'onu estiment que
d'ici la fin de l'année cela pourrait
monter jusqu'à 5 millions et demi de
ressortissants vénézuélien qui
quitteraient leur pays si pourquoi
l'union européenne a dégagé une
enveloppe de 55 millions d'euros d' aide
humanitaire depuis 2018
je voudrais enfin indiqué et je sais que
les sénateurs ils sont particulièrement
sensibles que le gouvernement se
mobilise pour garantir la protection des
quelques 4000 ressortissants français
qui sont demeurés sur place un certain
nombre de nos ressortissants à quitter
le pays
ophir au fur et à mesure de la
dégradation de la situation mais il
reste environ 4000 nous veillons à leur
sécurité et toutes les options sont
étudiées y compris la possibilité de
rapatrier ceux qui demanderaient à
l'être si la situation devait empirer
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
premier ministre
la parole est maintenant aux présidents
philippe bas pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président vous avez la
parole
ma question s'adressait à madame le
garde des sceaux mais celle ci n'a pas
pu nous rejoindre nous avons une vive
préoccupation celle du service public de
la justice
le service public de la justice est en
crise le service public de la justice
est en grande souffrance
nous avons constaté que les délais de
jugement ne cesse de s'allonger
les peines sont mal exécutée les prisons
sont saturés une réforme a été engagée
pour répondre à ces difficultés
cette réforme a suscité une hostilité
sans précédent de toutes les professions
de justice
nous les avons réunis hier en tables
rondes elles attendent plus de garanties
pour les droits des justiciables
elles attendent aussi plus de garanties
que la couverture de chacun de nos
territoires sera correctement assuré le
sénat partage intégralement ses
préoccupations ils vous demandent ils
demandent au gouvernement de bien
vouloir suspendre les travaux
parlementaires pour trouver un accord
qui permettra de faire en sorte que une
réponse appropriée pertinentes et
consensuelle soit apportée aux
préoccupations du monde de la justice
partagé par nos collectivités
non la parole le communisme en charge
des relations avec le parlement
lesieu fesneau merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le président bah je
vais tout d'abord excusé l'absence de la
garde des sceaux qui s'est rendu auprès
des personnels pénitentiaires à tarascon
après l'évasion intervenue en début de
semaine vous m'interrogez sur vous
interroger le gouvernement sur la
réforme de la justice qui est en cours
aujourd'hui à un stade avancé de la
navette parlementaire je sais que vous
avez organisé comme vous l'avez rappelé
une table ronde d'hier avec plusieurs
organisations du monde de la justice et
que vous avez également invité madame la
garde des sceaux à venir s'exprimer
devant la commission les lois ce qu'elle
a fait également hier au cours des
débats parlementaires qui se sont tenues
depuis octobre dernier on a pu observer
des points de convergence réelle autour
d'un objectif commun donner enfin à la
justice les moyens auxquels elle peut
pétant prétendre et la réforme et pour
prendre en compte les besoins des
justiciers jeu le président pas vous
annonce vous disiez à juste titre qu'il
y avait une vraie urgence sur la justice
et de ce fait je comprends moins d'une
certaine façon votre expression et à
demander finalement une pause parce
qu'il ya besoin et vous avez raison de
le dire d'une réforme profonde de la
justice qui répondent aux besoins des
justiciables
ces besoins sont ceux d'une justice de
proximité qui soit efficace et moderne
qui soit plus rapide et vous avez raison
de le rappeler et qui protège les
français tout en garantissant leurs
doigts sur les moyens d'atteindre ces
objectifs le sénat et l'assemblée
nationale ont divergé votre assemblée
partie d'une position qu'elle avait été
qu'elle avait élaboré dès le printemps
2017 et qui ne correspondaient pas au
choix à la fois fait part le gouvernant
après la consultation organisée dans le
cadre des chantiers de la justice au
cours de l'examen par l'assemblée
nationale le texte a évolué démontrant
l'ouverture du gouvernement et de la
majorité sur ce sujet je voudrais vous
rappeler que alors que le projet initial
prévoyait une répartition des
juridictions sur la carte administrative
qui est telle qu'elle était prévue jeudi
a été décidée par le gouvernement après
écoute des élus et des professions
judiciaires de choisir le manque de
maintien du maillage territorial de
justice tel qu'il avait été prévu si
vous dire si notre souhait constant
c'est de faire en sorte que la justice
soit écoutée et que les moyens soient
donnés la réforme arrive un stade de la
navette où le texte semble se dessiner
définitivement je ne doute pas que le
travail du sénat permettra
un certain nombre de dispositions et
c'est donc donc avec cet esprit là que
nous abordons la dernière lecture qui va
se dérouler désormais au sénat je
remercie monsieur le brésil est encore
monsieur le ministre regrette de vous
dire que cet esprit est un esprit de
fermeture
on ne peut pas avoir raison seul contre
tout le monde on ne peut pas réformer la
société par voie d'autorité c'est très
rare que les greffiers les magistrats
les avocats soient tous d'accord c'est
très rare qu'une assemblée comme le
sénat et trouver des points de
convergence qui coïncide avec les
attentes manifesté par les professions
de justice et je crois que le
gouvernement serait bien inspiré après
les troubles des dernières mois de
commencer à comprendre qu'une autre
méthode est préférable si on veut
réformer la société en profondeur
il faut d'abord recherché par le
dialogue davantage de consensus c'est ce
que nous vous offrons de faire en
essayant de dégager nous mêmes des
points d'accord avec les professions de
justice
merci la parole et
notre collègue dominique vais rien pour
le groupe de l'union centriste avait la
parole matcher collègues
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
monsieur le secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'action et des comptes
publics chargé de la fonction publique
vous avez prévu de réduire encore les
services de la direction générale des
finances publiques pour faire des
économies on ne peut vous en vouloir
mais une fois de plus elles se feront
sur les territoires plutôt qu'à bercy
cependant dans une note préparatoire de
décembre 2018
vos services prônait la concertation
locale la recherche d'un équilibre
territorial ou encore l'utilisation de
nouveaux outils comme la téléconférence
alors chiche monsieur le ministre
osez la concertation la vraie car un
courrier d'information envoyé un élu un
mois avant l'arrêt d'un service public
n'est pas une concertation et je vous
suggère dans vos nouveaux outils
d'intégrer les maisons de services au
public
elles sont en effet les derniers relais
de l'administration en milieu rural mais
pour cela il faudrait que les
administrations acceptent de collaborer
avec ses maisons ce qui n'est
malheureusement pas toujours le cas
alors monsieur le ministre vous qui
avait porté une loi qui prônait la
confiance comment pensez vous instaurez
confiance et partenariat entre les
services publics de l'état et ceux des
collectivités locales afin que tous nos
concitoyens est le même accès au droit
bon vous répondre à la parole et au
secrétariat aux produits du phoque sur
des comptes publics monsieur du soft sur
milices de mai la parole merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice vais rien
vous poser la question de la permanence
sur le territoire du réseau de la dgfip
vous avez raison de souligner son
importance
aujourd'hui la dgesip compte 3800 points
de contact c'est 1000 de moins qu'il ya
dix ans
qui témoigne de des réorganisations
successives ces réorganisations qui se
traduisait par les fermetures ont un
défaut principal au delà de la
justification de certaines du fait des
évolutions technologiques
elles s'inscrivent dans des plans
annuels sans visibilité ni pour les
agents ni pour les élus locaux nous
avons demandé avec gérald darmanin à
l'ensemble des services du ministère de
l'action des comptes publics de changer
cette méthode
cette nouvelle méthode va se traduire au
cours de l'année 2019 pas d'abord par
une méthode de concertation comme vous
les appelez de vos voeux
nous avons fixé aux directeurs
départementaux des finances publiques en
lien avec les préfets trois objectifs le
premier objectif est d'avoir une vision
pluriannuelle de la réorganisation des
services de la dgesip de manière à
donner la visibilité aux territoires aux
élus locaux aux agents et aux
contribuables
nous leur demandons aussi de réfléchir à
l'échelle de bassin de vie et de bassins
d'emploi en s'extrayant des logiques
purement administrative et en
travaillant plus tôt à l'échelle d'une
région sans tenir compte des frontières
administratives du département qui bien
souvent sont artificielles dans le
quotidien de nos concitoyens et nous
leur avons demandé de travailler en
augmentant le nombre de points de
contact sur le territoire par tous les
moyens possibles le maintien de
perception mais aussi le développement
maison de services au public et ma
collègue jacqueline gourault travail à
harmoniser l'offre de services dans les
maisons de services au public et veiller
à ce que l'ensemble des services de
l'état puisse y participer
j'ajoute madame la sénatrice deux points
le premier pour dire que nous veillions
dans cette entreprise là à garantir un
très bon niveau de conseil aux élus
locaux soit par les trésoriers eux mêmes
soit par la constitution des équipes de
référence polyvalente et organisés en
brigades et par ailleurs nous veillons
aussi à regarder comment des services
installé aujourd'hui à paris ou dans les
métropoles pourrait être à terme
installées dans les territoires ruraux
périurbains dans une entreprise de
déconcentration de proximité j'ajoute si
vous me le permettez monsieur le
président que les orientations données
au ministère de l'action et des comptes
publics sont parfaitement conformes aux
instructions données par le premier
ministre à l'ensemble des ministres pour
ce qui concerne la réorganisation des
services de l'état sur le territoire
on n'avait rien cette concertation est
prévue entre le 15 février et 15 mars
toujours dans la même note
j'espère que vous la ferez après le
grand débat et j'entends bien votre
réponse nous jugerons et si c'est le cas
merci la parole et que notre collègue
martin lévriers pour le groupe de la
république en marche pour deux minutes
faut vraiment que chacun respecte on
optera merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre du travail en 2018
691 1000 nouvelles sociétés ont vu le
jour
le chômage a reculé de 1 25% en année le
nombre de procédures prud'homales a
chuté de plus de 17 20 61 % 3 résultats
encourageants directement lié aux
ordonnances réformant le code du travail
et aux actions menées durant ces 18
dernières années ils ont permis aux
entreprises de se stabiliser de
reconstituer leurs marges et de
redevenir compétitive leurs capacités de
sauvegarde et créer des emplois et à
réinvestir s'est renforcée nous le
savons tous c'est l'entreprise qui
génère la richesse qui créent de
l'emploi et permet à tous de mieux vivre
dans un contexte économique instable
le gouvernement a maintenu ce cap ainsi
le projet de loi de finances 2010 neuf
actes entre autres le transfert du cic
eux vers un allègement de cotisations
patronales pour un coût de 21 milliards
d'euros madame la ministre en novembre
vous avez lancé la négociation entre
partenaires sociaux sur l'assurance
chômage a des objectifs est de lutter
contre la précarité inciter les chômeurs
à retourner plus vite sur le marché du
travail
or lundi les organisations patronales
ont décidé de se retirer des
négociations
faisant suite aux déclarations du
président de la république sur le bonus
malus
ce dispositif consiste à moduler les
cotisations chômage de l'employeur en
fonction du taux de rupture de contrat
de travail
cette promesse présidentielle a trouvé
le soutien des syndicats et pour cause
en vingt ans les cdd de moins d'un mois
ont été multipliés par deux et demi
madame la ministre nous devons continuer
à libérer l'économie française tout en
protégeant le salarié et cela ne peut se
faire qu'avec la collaboration du medef
de la cgpme et de l'ue de paix
que comptez vous faire pour que les
organisations patronales réintègre la
table des négociations je conclus et
dans l'éventualité d'un accord quelles
seraient les alternatives à la taxation
des contrats courts
je remercie madame la ministre vous avez
deux minutes maximum pour répondre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur martin lévriers
vous avez souligné le début de la baisse
du chômage dont on est passé de 9,7 à
9,1 pour cent avec 250 mille emplois en
créations nettes
c'est encourageant je pense que nous
serons tous d'accord ici pour dire qu'il
faut aller il faut encore plus continuer
nos efforts pour aller dans ce sens-là
c'est le sens des ordonnances de la loi
pour la liberté de choisir son avenir
professionnel et le plan
d'investissement compétences dont je
peux vous dire d'ores et déjà que treize
régions sur 15 heures aux régions sur
treize pardon me confirmer leur accord
pour signer ce pacte lors quatre ans
ainsi que tous les outre-mer
mais au-delà de ça un des leviers et ce
sont aussi les règles de l'assurance
chômage et dans les règles d'assurance
chômage dans le document de cadrage que
le premier ministre a envoyé le 25
septembre dernier aux partenaires
sociaux trois sujets principaux sont
évoqués un premier concerne les règles
d'indemnisation des chômeurs puisque
dans 20% des cas ce n'est pas la
totalité
le cumul de plusieurs règles sans que
ces faits déterminés par les partenaires
sociaux et était voulue au pour
conséquence que dans ces cas là 1 un
demandeur d'emploi indemnisé peut avoir
une indemnité qui est supérieur chaque
mois à ce qu'ils avaient en travaillant
chaque mois ce n'est pas incitatif
il ya un autre sujet qui est très
important c'est la multiplication jeu si
j'ose dire l'explosion des contrats
courts dans notre pays est une
spécificité française
malheureusement qui concourent beaucoup
à la précarité dont on voit à quel point
elle est un sujet sensible à juste titre
dans la population
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
9 embauches sur dix sont un contrat en
cdd ou un intérim mais plus encore
aujourd'hui ce sont les cdd extrêmement
courts qui sont développés puisque ce
sont 80 % de cdd
qui sont de trois mois au moins et
aujourd'hui nous avons une explosion des
contrats de moins d'un mois en
particulier dans douze secteurs
professionnels qui ont multiplié par
deux et demi leur contrat extrêmement
court ah non une précarisation de tout
un secteur du pont du travail
c'est donc la responsabilité aussi des
employeurs de travailler sur ce sujet et
avec le premier ministre
faisons confiance à la négociation
sociale pour trouver des solutions sur
ces deux sujets on conclure
désendettement de l'unedic dont je
rappelle qu'il ya 35 milliards de da
dette garantie par l'état
les trois collègues françoise laborde
pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen pour
devenu merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
l'aéroport régional toulouse blagnac vie
à un énième rebondissement avec
l'annoncé par le consortium chinois
quasi l'europe de la revente des 49 9%
de parts qu'il détient depuis 2015
les acteurs locaux sont las de ce
mauvais scénario sur lequel je me suis
maintes fois exprimée ici nous parlons
du cinquième aéroport régional et
premier aéroport régional de fret outils
de développement essentiel pour le
territoire infrastructures hautement
stratégiques notamment pour airbus qui
en est un utilisateur privilégié depuis
l'arrivée de quasi l'europe
un bras de fer s'est engagée concernant
la redistribution des dividendes
l'investisseur privé réclamant je cite
un retour sur investissement raisonnable
les collectivités locales n'ont cessé de
se poser de s'opposer à la demande de
redistribution croissante qui a atteint
fin 2010 8 100 % des bénéfices elles
n'ont pas plus été aidé par l' agence de
participation de l'état qui a
systématiquement valider les attentes de
l'investisseur privé
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous me
garantir que les derniers 10,1 pour cent
appartenant encore à l'état seront bien
désolidarisé de la vente par quasi
l'europe à tout nouvel acheteur privé
je propose d'étudier une vente des parts
de l'état aux collectivités locales qui
détiennent déjà ensemble 40% du capital
afin d'assurer une majorité stable et
sereine
dans la gouvernance de cet équipement je
vous remercie merci à bord le touriste
de l'économie et des finances monsieur
le maire
ce président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice la bande
en avril 2015
nous avons vendu 49 et 2 9% départ de
l'aéroport de toulouse nous avons mené
cette opération en respect des règles de
droit en faisant un appel à concurrence
un système d'enchères et donc nous avons
vendu comme c'est le cas dans n'importe
quel écho been marché à l'acheteur qui
était le plus offrant qui répondait au
cahier des charges
je rappelle que kaz il était plus
offrants de 17% par rapport à l'an
scherrer qui venait en deuxième position
je rappelle également que la cour des
comptes a validé cette enchère et a
reconnu qu' elle était parfaitement
conforme aux règles de droit
je le dis pour ce qui pourrait contester
la légalité de cette opération qui ne se
gêne pas pour le faire
la troisième remarque que je tiens à
faire c'est que depuis 2015 qu'est ce
qui s'est passé sur l'aéroport de
toulouse les investissements sur
lesquelles ce gaz il était engagé ont
été faits
le trafic a augmenté de 28% des
résultats financiers de l'entreprise ont
augmenté de 28%
tant que nous sommes dans une économie
de marché de devrions nous réjouir que
l'aéroport de toulouse est de nouveaux
investissements des financements qui
soit solide et des passagers qu'ils
soient plus nombreux parce que c'est
bien ce que nous cherchons le
développement économique
ensuite il reste 10 % de parts qui
appartiennent à l'état
je vous fais une proposition honnête
madame la sénatrice
c'est de venir de venir me voir
avec les autres élus avec les autres
élus de la métropole avec la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie et que nous
discutions de ce que vous voulez que
nous fassions nous prendrons la décision
ensemble chaud et 10% de participation
de l'état qui reste dans l'aéroport de
toulouse avec un seul objectif le
développement de votre aéroport laborde
merci monsieur le ministre j'avoue que
votre réponse me convient et que je
viendrais parce que je pense que c'est
important que nous puissions discuter de
cet équipement qui n'est pas n'importe
quel équipement et donc c'est vrai qu'il
faut le traiter différemment et j'espère
que les collectivités pourront garder
les 10,1 pour cent restants je vous
remercie
la parole est à madame lienemann pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes vous avez la parole
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
monsieur le ministre les géants du
numérique les gars femmes paient des
impôts dérisoire de notre pays notre
groupe depuis plusieurs années dans le
débat budgétaire a déposé des
amendements pour stopper cette injustice
elle ce manque à gagner le sénat où delà
de nos différences politiques
les a à plusieurs reprises voter et
récemment encore lors de la loi de
finances
le gouvernement les a rejetées on ne
pouvait agir qu'au niveau européen voire
à l' ocde
certes c'est indispensable mais cela
n'empêchait pas la france d'agir en
précurseur et de façon unilatérale sur
la pression de l'opinion vous en
convenez désormais et promettez de taxer
les gars femmes que de temps et d'argent
perdu mais cette accession ne doit pas
être symbolique
d'abord le cadre doit être durable
ces entreprises doivent être taxés comme
toutes celles installées sur notre
territoire alors proposerez-vous comme
le sénat
que les géants du numérique soit
considérée comme établissement stable en
france dès lors que leur chiffre
d'affaires dépasse un certain seuil dans
notre pays
porterez-vous cette exigence alou c'est
dire
ensuite les discussions européennes
prévoit une taxe de 3% sur les chiffres
d'affaires
mais sous la pression de l'allemagne la
base prise en compte pour le chiffre
d'affaires a fondu comme neige au soleil
initialement la france pouvait escompter
un milliard d'euros de recettes en
rythme de croisière avec l'accord
franco-allemand que vous avez approuvé
elle ne serait plus que de 400 millions
ce qui vous en conviendrez est assez
dérisoire au regard de leurs profits
alors proposerez-vous une base large de
taxation permettant une recette
d'environ un milliard d'euros pour notre
pays
nous sommes inquiets car les
informations d'ap rès n'ont pas l'air
d'aller en ce sens il en va de la
justice fiscale entre citoyens et
entreprises entre entreprises pme qui
payent beaucoup et multinationales qui
paye peut il en va des moyens dont la
france conclure 1 il est urgent que les
gars femmes payent leur dû monsieur le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
madame la sénatrice lienemann ça nous
arrivera
rarement je pense dans cet hémicycle
mais pour une fois je suis d'accord avec
vous il est indispensable de taxer sans
délai les géants du numérique
c'est une question de justice personne
ne peut accepter que les géants du
numérique qui font les profits les plus
élevés paye 14 points d'impôts de moins
que n'importe quelle pme de france ou
d'europe et c'est une question
d'efficacité
parce que si nous voulons demain pouvoir
financer nos services publics nos
crèches nos hôpitaux nos écoles bien il
faut aller chercher l'argent là où il se
trouve et c'est ce que nous allons faire
et c'est ce que nous allons faire
à la demande à la demande du premier
ministre nous déposerons dans les
prochains jours un projet de loi sur la
taxation des géants du numérique
cette taxation nationale des gens du
numérique touchera toutes les
entreprises qui ont un chiffre
d'affaires numérique supérieures à 750
millions d'euros et un chiffre
d'affaires national supérieur à 25
millions d'euros la taxation sera
progressive cela devrait vous plaire
pour que les petits pays moins que les
gros et le rapport de cette taxe sera
d'environ 500 millions d'euros chaque
année
mais je ne baisse pas les bras pour que
nous obtenions aussi l'accord des 27
états membres de l'union européenne sur
une taxation européenne des géants du
numérique parce que tout de même plutôt
que d'avoir une taxe française italienne
espagnole et britannique
il serait mieux que l'europe est enfin
le courage d'assumer ses positions de
défendre ses intérêts économiques et de
taxer de manière souveraine
les géants du numérique dans le monde
nous nous battrons conclure ce qu'on
vous et j'espère qu'avec notre y compris
au niveau européen nous aurons des
causes pour la justice et l'efficacité
du système fiscal du 21e siècle
merci la parole est à notre collègue
xavier iacovelli pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain
il avait la parole pour deux minutes et
nous revient que j'ai dans l'intention
de temps soit respectée merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse
secrétaire d'état auprès de la ministre
des solidarités chez ministre deux morts
par semaine un viol toutes les heures
40% des sans domicile fixe de moins de
25 ans sont d'anciens enfants placés 70%
des jeunes qui sortent de la zone sont
sans diplôme
monsieur le ministre il s'est levé dans
notre pays un vent d'indignation sur le
sort de la république réserve à ses
enfants
il aura fallu un documentaire choc sur
france 3 la mobilisation des députés et
sénateurs de tous les bords politiques
et l'émotion des français pour que le
gouvernement se décide enfin à agir
indignation monsieur ministre qui a
conduit à votre nomination le 25 janvier
dernier
en dix-huit mois votre gouvernement a
perdu la confiance de l'ensemble des
acteurs de la protection de l'enfance en
en faisant l'angle mort de votre
politique
cette confiance il est de votre devoir
de la retrouver cette situation
dramatique ne date pas d'hier
les départements qui sont confrontés à
la baisse des dotations à l'augmentation
des placements et des suivis ne peuvent
plus gérer seul la prise des charges de
ses enfants
comment accepter que l'aide sociale à
l'enfance censé être le lieux de
protection devienne le lieu de
reproduction des violences contre
lesquels les enfants doivent être
protégés
comment accepter que perdure de telles
inégalités de prise en charge des
terribles d'un territoire à l'autre
sortie sèche de l'ac2a 18 ans
vieillissement des familles d'accueil
absence de fichier national pour
l'agrément notre système de protection
de l'enfance est aujourd'hui à bout de
souffle
pouvez vous monsieur le ministre
préciser quel est votre périmètre
le périmètre de votre ministère et quels
seront les moyens attribués pour la
protection de l'enfance sachant que rien
n'était prévu dans le budget 2010 9 en
tant que député vous avez signé la
proposition de loi pour éviter les
sorties sèches des jeunes majeurs en
tant que ministre allez-vous soutenir
les initiatives parlementaires pour vous
répondre le parent le secrétaire d'état
auprès de la ministre des solidarités de
la sorte et monsieur adria taquet merci
monsieur le président pour votre pour
votre accueil
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur iacovelli
je vous remercie pour votre question
tout d'abord ce qu'elle me permet de
saluer ce département des hauts-de-seine
qui nous est chère à vous et à moi dont
nous sommes tous les deux issus votre
question permet de saluer ensuite votre
engagement votre engagement fox en
faveur la protection de l'enfance sujet
dont je sais qu'il vous est cher et nous
partageons cette nous partageons cette
préoccupation salue enfin les
initiatives qui est la vôtre
il y a quelques jours avec certains un
certain nombre de votre de vos collègues
et je ne peux que saluer cette
initiative et au delà
au-delà de votre travail celui de
l'ensemble des membres de la commission
des affaires sociales qui travaillent
sur ce sujet vous me rejoindrez je pense
pour dire que la préoccupation la
situation est trop grande pour qu'elle
puisse être le monopole d'une couleur
politique ou de certains bancs autour
d'eux au sein de cette assemblée soit
ils ont convaincu je ne serai pas le
ministre qui oppose les parents à leurs
enfants qui oppose les juges aux avocats
qui opposerait les travailleurs sociaux
à leur employeur je ne serai pas le
ministre qui opposera les départements à
l'état je ne serai pas le ministre qui
opposera cette partie là de l'hémicycle
à celle ci je serai le ministe de la
concertation et du dialogue
oui un dialogue franc et sincère où on
se dit les choses dans les yeux et où
chacun chacun assume ses responsabilités
un dialogue qui assure qui est associé à
votre assemblée les départements et les
communes
ces territoires que vous représentez les
associations les professionnels de santé
que vous avez cités et du monde éducatif
les enfants oui les enfants et les
parents pour trouver ensemble des
solutions trouver ensemble des solutions
pour prévenir les violences tout d'abord
en accompagnant les parents et les
futurs parents trouver des solutions
ensemble pour mieux repérer ces
violences fort a conclu ou v des
solutions ensemble pour protéger
efficacement les enfants victimes pour
leur offrir des parcours de vie stable
notamment la sortie de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance
enfin pour leur garantir les droits
fondamentaux comme l'éducation et la
santé
toujours merci je soyez sûr que je serai
au rendez vous je compte sur vous et sur
l'ensemble des membres de cette
assemblée pour conclusion des solutions
d'ici à l'été prochain je vous remercie
key a corrigé quelques secondes oui mais
monsieur le ministre malheureusement je
ne suis pas complètement satisfait de
votre réponse et notamment sur le
périmètre et sur les moyens qui vous
sont attribués
puisque votre ministre de tutelle a
déclaré le jour de votre nomination
devant le cnpe que vous n'aviez ni
budget et que vous étiez secrétaire
d'état à l'enfance contredisant du coup
le premier ministre quelques minutes
avant
concernant ces trois patrons nous sommes
effectivement concluant responsable
monsieur le ministre il ya urgence et
nous comptons sur votre action
merci la parole est maintenant à madame
la présidente sophie primas pour le
groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre chargé de la ville
et du logement que je remercie pour sa
présence monsieur le ministre
voici presque deux ans vous avez pris
les rênes de ce ministère sous une forme
ou sous une autre
et les choix du gouvernement ont
désormais des conséquences sur la marche
du pays
force est de constater que la relance du
logement a été l'une de vos premières
préoccupations
malheureusement ce fut aussi la cible
des foudres de bercy la construction du
logement connaît aujourd'hui un sérieux
ralentissement les chiffres 2018 sont
inquiétants
le nombre de mises en chantier a baissé
de 18% en 2018
coup de frein qui s'est amplifié en fin
d'année
plus grave le nombre de permis de
construire délivrés ce qui fait l'avenir
baisse en 2018 et le recul au quatrième
trimestre s'est accentuée enfin
peut-être encore plus inquiétant le taux
d'annulation des logements collectifs
autorisés ont atteint en fin d'année
27,3 pour cent le gouvernement voulait
être jugé sur ses résultats
nous y sommes exclusion de certaines
zones du dispositif pinel la fin de
l'acccident de la paix à l'accession la
limitation du prêt à taux zéro la coupe
dans les ressources des bailleurs
sociaux
toutes ces décisions purement budgétaire
auront produit leurs effets
malheureusement sur tous ces bancs lors
de l'examen des plf en 2018 en 2019 ou
de la loi élan les sénateurs vous avait
alerté sur les conséquences président
prévisible de vos choix
philippe dallier dominique estrosi entre
autres
ne regrettez vous pas monsieur le
ministre quand vous voyez les chiffres
de ce bilan de ne pas avoir écouté le
sénat au projet de loi de finances comme
vous l'avez mieux fait en loi élan aux
réformes la parole et au ministère du
logement monsieur de normandie vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la présidente prima vous l'avez
vous avez raison vous l'avez évoqué les
chiffres de la construction en 2018 sont
moins bons que ceux de 2017 c'est à peu
près un peu moins de 400 mille logements
qui ont été commencées à peu près quatre
cent soixante mille logements qui ont
été autorisés
ça reste néanmoins vis-à-vis de l'année
2007 qui était une année exceptionnelle
ça reste néanmoins des chiffres qui sont
bien supérieurs à la moyenne des cinq
dernières années c'est à peu près 25
mille logements commencés de plus que
sur la moyenne des cinq dernières années
mais peu importe cela ce qui est sûr
c'est que aujourd'hui dans notre pays
il manque encore significativement des
logements songez qu'au moment où je vous
parle on construit à peu près autant de
logements qu'au début des années 80
alors qu'il y à 13 millions de
concitoyens en plus et une pression sur
les logements de plus en plus forte avec
notamment des divorces qui se sont
multipliés et alors qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire vis-à-vis de cela il ya trois
choses principales la première c'est de
mettre en oeuvre massivement et avec
beaucoup de rapidité la loi élan sur
laquelle vous êtes tente impliqué madame
la présidente ainsi que madame la
rapporteur dominique estrosi sassone je
vous remercie d'ailleurs parce que vous
avez accepté participer à ce comité de
suivi inédit que nous lançons dès mardi
prochain en votre présence
avec également vos collègues de
l'assemblée nationale deuxièmement il
faut lever les inquiétudes lever les
inquiétudes là où elle se trouve
notamment dans le logement social nous
étions hier avec votre collègue monsieur
le sénateur d'alliés pour la deuxième
réunion de la clause de revoyure et je
salue la présence et la participation
active de monsieur le sénateur d'allier
à ces travaux le troisième élément qu'il
nous faut faire c'est absolument pouvoir
poursuivre la réhabilitation également
des logements parce qu'il s'avère qu'il
ya la construction il faut la soutenir
par le truchement de la loi élan là où
elle est nécessaire mais il ya aussi la
réhabilitation ou les chiffres pour le
coup sont bien meilleures puisque cette
année si je ne
on que l'ana uniquement l'activité de
l'anah c'est 17% de plus de
réhabilitation qui ont été opérés et je
crois que un certain nombre de tragédies
notamment le drame de marseille nous ont
rappelé au combien cette réhabilitation
était nécessaire et que cette approche
de logements que je sais vous partagez
madame la présidente d'une approche
différenciée en fonction des territoires
et peut-être ce qui a manqué pendant un
bout de temps et ce qu'il nous faut
aujourd'hui remettre en place
oui merci monsieur le ministre de cette
réponse mais vous savez très bien
monsieur le ministre je m'adresse aussi
au premier ministre danser danser dans
son budget que la sensibilité du
logement au budget aux décisions
budgétaires est extrêmement forte et
quand on a mis un coup de frein aussi
fort que celui qu'on a mis cette année
et bien pour redémarrer cette
construction ça sera extrêmement
compliqué et malgré la loi est lent
malgré la simplification qu'on est en
train d'opérer avec pacte tout ça n'aura
pas d'effet si on met pas un moment les
moyens pour le logement
merci la parole et à notre collègue
nathalie goulet
mais pour le groupe de l'union centriste
mais la parole messieurs mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre c'est le premier ministre la
plupart des pays dont la france exige
des gens qui voyagent en france et
ailleurs un billet de retour
c'est normal ça évite les problèmes et
ça garantit le retour des gens qui
viennent sur le territoire or il se
trouve que des entreprises pleine de
créativité ont initié la vente de
billets provisoire sur internet c'est à
dire que ces billets pour 7 à 30 dollars
sont valables entre quelques heures et
plusieurs jours c'est à dire que quand
vous vous présentez à la passerelle de
l'avion et au contrôle vous avez un
billet de retour
et puis quand vous avez passé les
bagages deux pays destination le biais
s'évapore voilà donc ces faux billets
vrai faux billets sont utilisés pour
obtenir un visa y compris un visa
schengen voyez-vous et donc je peux vous
donner la référence des sites mais je
voudrais pas leur créer trop de
publicité donc ma question est la
suivante monsieur le ministre
dans la période que nous traversons
quelles mesures comptez vous prendre
pour éviter ce type de procédure et et
faire en sorte soit au niveau national
et en tous les cas au niveau européen
qu'on limite les effets dévastateurs de
ces agences très créatrice pour vous
répondre la parole est et cas monsieur
willis de l'intérieur monsieur
christophe scolaire monsieur ministrère
si monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice à travers votre question sur
ces faux billets ou ses billets
temporaire vous poser celle plus globale
au fond des fraudes documentaires des
fraudes documentaires que nous
retrouvons sur les questions d'identité
et qu'ils aient perpétré dans des pays
tiers et qui a tendance est
effectivement à prendre de l'ampleur
c'est d'une ampleur que vous évoquez
dont nous avons conscience que nous
devons combattre parce que ces
tentatives de fraude elles peuvent se
manifester à toutes les étapes du
parcours migratoire y compris d'un pays
à l'autre dans les pays de transit et
nous faut sur ces sujets être très
vigilant parce que pour certains pays il
faut l'obtention d'un visa et pour
traverser ce pays pour venir ensuite
vers un pays schengen on a des faux
visas on a aussi des titres de séjour et
globalement c'est aussi une fraude
documentaire qui permet d'échapper à
tous nos dispositifs qui sont
consécutifs à l'éloignement qui peut
être mises en oeuvre et qui du coup
aujourd'hui permettent d'empêcher
d'empêcher une bonne lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière parce que dans
ce pays il ya des règles il ya des
règles qui se veulent généreuse sur
l'accueil des personnes en situation de
réfugiés qui doivent être appliquées
pour des migrations économiques et pour
des migrants qui n'ont pas vocation à
rester dans notre pays vous m'interrogez
sur les moyens que nous mettons en
oeuvre ils sont de plusieurs niveaux
d'abord dans chaque département pour
travailler sur l'ensemble des filières
nous avons mis en place une un comité
opérationnel départemental anti fraude
qui associe le préfet le procureur pour
travailler sur tous ces sujets on a la
connaissance la en aval c'est-à-dire à
l'arrivée d'un certain nombre
d'informations qui peuvent nous
permettre de lutter contre les filières
en 2018 nous avons démantelé 52 filière
qu'ils utilisent et qui mettaient en
place des faux documents
près de douze mille agents ont été
formés aussi pour travailler sur ces
sujets et pour faire en sorte qu'on
puisse avancer nous multiplions aussi
les officiers de liaison dans les
aéroports les plus sensibles pour
utiliser un euphémisme pour justement
détecter ces faux papiers et ses
arnaques sur les billets d'avion
l'année dernière c'est près de cas de 49
mille documents qui ont été analysés à
la demande de différents services police
préfecture tribunaux et il est
nécessaire que nous maintenions l'effort
parce qu'effectivement nul ne peut
pouvoir contourner ces règles
fondamentales et nous devons sur ces
sujets être extrêmement vigilant en
particulier sur les faux billets d'avion
[Applaudissements]
madame fondatrice oui le simili sûr
merci moi j'ai un petit troubles
obsessionnels compulsifs sur la fraude
documentaire vous vous savez et donc je
voulais quand même vous signaler on
l'avait déjà signalé dans le cadre de la
du rapport sur les réseaux djihadistes
vous savez que la police de l'air et des
frontières n'a toujours pas accès au
fichier tess c'est quand même très
réducteur de leurs capacités par
ailleurs en ce qui concerne les mesures
d'usurpation d'identité je pense qu'il
faudra renforcer les articles 44 141
441,2 dans la future loppsi
il faut renforcer les sanctions et puis
s'agissant de la fraude documentaire
notamment en matière de sécurité sociale
je voudrais remercier l'initiative du
rapporteur général du budget de la
sécurité sociale qui va enfin procéder à
une enquête sur pièces et sur place
en ce qui concerne les faux numéro digne
c'est qu'ils sont un sujet régulier de
de problème compte tenu des montants
extrêmement important de fraude
documentaire jour merci merci la parole
est à ma collègue frank mohn en ville
devant le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole monsieur le président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'agriculture
elle porte sur la peste porcine
africaine maladie hémorragique virale
strictement animal la peste porcine
africaine est à paris en europe de l'est
il y a cinq ans elle a peu à peu avancée
vers l'ouest du continent pour atteindre
la belgique le 13 septembre dernier
neuf pays de l'union européenne sont
déjà concernés deux nouveaux cas ont été
détectés en belgique le 14 janvier
dernier
à moins de deux kilomètres de la
frontière non transmissible à l'homme
il faut le rappeler
elle se révèle toutefois extrêmement
contagieuse pour les porcins et les
sangliers les risques d'une arrivée en
france du virus sans considérable tout
d'abord pour notre agriculture en
particulier pour la filière porcine car
au-delà donc du risque sanitaire et de
la mortalité
c'est aussi le marché de l'exportation
qui se fermerait entraînant
l'anéantissement des débouchés pour les
producteurs
l'industrie agroalimentaire ne serait
sans doute pas épargné non plus un fort
risque pèse aussi sur la biodiversité
sur l'activité forestière est sûre
l'économiste cynégétique
vous avez pris des mesures de prévention
dont la mise en place d'une zone blanche
où sont éradiqués tous les cent dix
principaux vecteurs de la propagation et
je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer la forte
mobilisation des chasseurs monsieur le
ministre pouvait nous dire si le pouvez
vous nous dire si la france est toujours
un thème quelles mesures à moyen et long
terme entendez vous mettre en place pour
lutter contre ce fléau
comment comptez vous accompagner et
protéger nos éleveurs et en vain enfin
pouvez vous nous dire comment s'articule
la coordination avec les autorités
belges merci pour vos réponses
la parole est à monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture monsieur didier guillaume
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur frank maintenant ville merci
pour votre question et merci pour votre
implication pour essayer de régler ce
problème comme l'ont très bien fait avec
lesquels nous travaillons beaucoup
benoît huré gérard longuet et marc
laménie avec lesquels il a en fait déjà
plusieurs réunions sur le sur le sur le
terrain cette situation situation est
très préoccupante est très grave pour la
france vous l'avez dit la france est
indemne
cette maladie ne peut pas être n'est pas
transmissible à l'homme
par contre cette maladie transmissible à
tous les élevages porcins avec deux
risques si un cas de peste porcine
africaine été découvert en france plus
aucun port à l'export dès le lendemain
c'est à dire c'est la moitié de de la
filière porcine qui deviendrait dans un
drôle d'état et la deuxième la deuxième
chose c'est tout simplement qu'il
faudrait comme il n'ya pas de
régionalisation il ferait vraisemblement
faire disparaître la plupart des
élevages porcins en france la france est
indemne
nous travaillons beaucoup avec la avec
la belgique depuis le 8 janvier
quand deux sangliers tués à côté de la
frontière est atteint par la maladie ont
été découverts nous avons réhausser le
niveau de biosécurité des élevages
réhausser le niveau de sécurité de notre
pays et réhaussée et mis en place une
task force avec les belges où toutes les
48 heures nous nous travaillons
enfin troisième chose en pré l'édition
de mettre un vide sanitaire 43 km de
long 6 km de large
à l'intérieur duquel nous devons tuer
tous les sangliers
je veux remercier l'ensemble des
services de l'état le préfet la draf le
ntfs l'unef
les chasseurs vous là vous l'avez dit
toute la filière inaporc la fédération
nationale porcine
la mobilisation générale est décrétée il
faut mettre dans gagner et pour gagner
il faut éradiquer la présence de
sangliers dans cette zone qui doit être
totalement une zone blanche le premier
ministre a autorisé à ce que nous soyons
aidées par l'armée des militaires 30 40
50 par jour viennent aider le
le travail qui est fait évidemment pas
pour tirer sur les sangliers mais pour
les pièger pour le transport de deux
cadavres
aujourd'hui nous avons environ 900
personnes qui organisent des battues
régulière nous en sommes à 200 250
sangliers il faut aller plus loin
mesdames et messieurs sida des chasseurs
de sangliers dans l'hémicycle faites
vous connaître vous serez les bienvenus
pour faire des beaux tableaux je
remercie merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue propre nom ville pardonnez moi
il avait les observations n'ont pas la
parole et à notre collègue alain larcher
pour le groupe mais républicain monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale mais
je crois qu'il n'est pas là il y a un an
je vous interrogeait déjà sur les
projets de fermetures de classes dans
les communes rurales de notre pays
aujourd'hui la situation qui s'annonce
est encore pire
vos promesses se sont envolés des
dizaines de classes vont encore fermées
et la france périphérique se sent plus
que jamais abandonné en seine-et-marne
en annonce près de 180 fermetures
touchent en plus de 150 communes sur 507
contre moins d'un tiers d'ouverture
les habitants sont exaspérés les élus
locaux sont désespérés nos villes et nos
villages ne pourront pas faire face
monsieur le ministre en fermant ses
classes quel avenir réservé vous au
monde rural la parole pour vous répondre
et au secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse
si gabriel talent vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice chien larcher je
vous prie d'excuser effectivement jean
michel blanquer requis et à l'assemblée
nationale pour l'examen d'une
proposition de loi sur l'école inclusive
vous posez la question de l'école et
dans la ruralité qui est un sujet un
sujet sensible parce qu'il renvoie à la
question la présence des services
publics dans nos territoires et dans nos
territoires ruraux en particulier sur ce
sujet je veux rappeler l'effort colossal
budgétaire qui a été déployée par le
gouvernement depuis deux ans pour
renforcer la présence colère dans la
ruralité vous prenez les 45 départements
les plus ruraux en 2017 et 2018
ces quarante mille élèves en moins et
pourtant 400 postes créés en plus la
démographie aurait dû conduire
mathématiquement le phare a
statistiquement comme c'est prévu selon
les règles à la suppression de postes la
suppression de casques de classe c des
postes supplémentaires qui ont été créés
ça va se poursuivre en 2010 neuf puisque
on attend encore une baisse
démographique et que au national de 1235
postes seront créés dans votre
département de seine et marne
ces 700 élèves en moins qui sont
attendus à la rentrée 2010 9
ce sera 40 professeurs en plus qui
arriveront en seine-et-marne à la
rentrée 2010 9 c'est donc un effort
important
je veux insister sur le fait que le
président de la république s'est engagé
lors de la conférence nationale des
territoires à ce qu'il y ait une
vigilance accrue des services
académiques sur la question des
fermetures de classes et plus gravement
encore sur la question des fermetures
d'écoles dans la ruralité parce que
c'est un sujet qui peut se présenter
s'il ya une baisse drastique de la
démographie si on veut maintenir un
niveau de qualité éducative importance
et des sujets qui peuvent se poser
ils doivent toujours se poser en lien
avec les élus locaux évidemment avec les
parlementaires du territoire c'est la
consigne qui est donné aux services
académiques
je rappelle par ailleurs que à ce stade
vous faites référence à la rentrée
prochaine
toutes les fermetures ouvertures de
classes qui sont annoncés ou prévues
sont conditionnelles rien n'a été acté
rien n'est acté c'est bien les
inscriptions constater les anticipations
constater qu'ils décideront bien plus
tard dans l'année des ouvertures et
fermetures de classes je veux aussi
rappeler que nous avons déployés en deux
coups
mention ruralité une dizaine en 2018
grâce notamment à l'implication du
sénateur alain durand votre collègue et
qu'une mission est en cours avec madame
azéma et monsieur macho pour travailler
sur la question de l'éducation et des
territoires et notamment de la ruralité
nous aurons ces retours dans les
prochaines semaines et sans doute
sera-t-il des adaptations à prévoir au
niveau national je vous remercie madame
aicha marché
monsieur le ministre des adaptations
nous les attendons effectivement parce
que l'art et à la réalité je vais vous
la dire c'est dans un même regroupement
pédagogique de fermeture en deux ans
coup sur coup
comment voulez vous que les maires face
vous nous parler chiffres choix
perspective est fort mais qui fait des
efforts nous vous parlons d'enfants qui
sont nos adultes de demain dont le seul
tort est de vivre à la campagne mais
aussi des kits d'enseignants qui font un
travail remarquable et qui ont besoin de
stabilité de villes et de villages dont
le dynamisme va être anéanti des
territoires qui souffre et que vous
refuser d'entendre après les entreprises
les commerces les médecins maintenant
les écoles mais ces français que vous
voyez comme ceux qui ne sont rien et
ceux qui roulent au diesel et fument des
clopes
eux aussi sont la france vous leur
promettait un grand débat et en même
temps vous ne leur laissait aucune
chance
tout cela n'est qu'enfumage vous
organisez la france des clivages vous ne
répare et pas la france comme cela
la parole est à notre collègue pascal
allizard pour le groupe l'est
républicain
il avait la parole mon cher collègue ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
ces dernières années de nombreux
français ont rejoint les rangs de l'état
islamique au levant acquis à la cause
salafistes portée par la volonté de
contribuer au djihad armé ils se sont
rendu tristement célèbre par leur part
leurs exactions commises contre les
populations locales pour imposer l'ordre
tyrannique de dèche
il voulait aussi mettre la france à
genoux certains d'entre eux utilisant
les réseaux sociaux ont largement
diffuser leur propagande visant à
encourager de jeunes français à les
rejoindre ou à commettre des attentats
sur notre sol par tous les moyens
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de ces
individus dangereux capturés en syrie
sont détenus par les forces kurdes
le désengagement américain du levant
pose la question du devenir de ces
prisonniers qui pourrait revenir en
france
dès lors comment le gouvernement tente
il protéger efficacement les français de
ces criminels de ses ennemis de la
république
et alors que la menace terroriste reste
très élevé dans notre pays
pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur le premier ministre
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur allizard
vous m'interrogez sur le sort des
français terroristes détenus au nord-est
de la syrie
je voudrais commencer par dire que votre
préoccupation celle qui sous-tend votre
question la préoccupation du premier
ministre que je suis des membres du
gouvernement de l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale
j'en suis certain c'est de faire en
sorte de garantir la sécurité des
français
c'est pour garantir la sécurité des
français que des gouvernements ont
décidé d'aller combattre des shs dans
cette région et de participer à une
coalition
c'est pour garantir la sécurité des
français qu'un certain nombre
d'opérations ont été conduites
face à des terroristes qui quelle que
soit la nationalité dont ils pouvaient
le cas échéant se revendiquait étaient
des ennemis et on est traité comme tel
il se trouve qu'un certain nombre de
combattants français qui se sont rendus
sur place ont été parfois rejoints par
leurs conjoints ont parfois eu des
enfants il se trouve que certains ont
été tués dans des combats que d'autres
sont aujourd'hui en détention par les
forces kurdes dans le nord-est de la
syrie
l'objectif notre objectif c'est
évidemment de faire en sorte que ceux
qui ont commis ces crimes
et il ne s'agissait pas d'une visite de
courtoisie à l'est au cours de ces
années dans cette région
c'est clairement faire un choix notre
objectif c'est que ferran de faire en
sorte que ceux qui ont fait ce choix
soit jugé soit condamné et soient punis
à la hauteur de leurs crimes et leurs
crimes sont immenses et monsieur le
sénateur
lorsque en irak lorsqu en irak un
certain nombre de ces français qui se
sont rendus coupables de crimes commis
en irak ont été arrêtés détenus jugés et
condamnés
nous n'avons rien trouvé à redire la
situation est un peu différente et vous
le savez parfaitement l autre question
l'illustrent dans le nord-est de la
syrie
pourquoi parce que ceux qui sont détenus
aujourd'hui sont détenus par les kurdes
parce que la décision unilatérale des
états unis de se désengager de la syrie
a suscité chez les kurdes des
interrogations considéra et pourrait
susciter et je le dis évidemment avec
beaucoup de prudence car je suis
incapable de la firme est ici mais
pourrait susciter des décisions de
réorganisation de l'effort des forces
d'autres priorités qui pourrait là
encore je le dis avec prudence avoir
pour effet non pas de garder en
détention
ces terroristes mais de les relâcher de
les disperser
et vous voyez bien monsieur le sénateur
qu'il n'est dans l'intérêt de personne
et certainement pas de notre pays de
voir se disperser des ennemis de la
france
ce que je veux dire monsieur le sénateur
c'est que si ces personnes sont expulsés
de syrie
et si elle venait à être en contact avec
les autorités françaises elles seraient
contents des mois bien immédiatement
arrêté soumis à la justice
et je l'espère je le crois puni et punis
sévèrement
c'est notre objectif faire en sorte que
ceux qui se sont rendus coupables de
crimes et le simple fait d'avoir été sur
place et souvent déjà constitutifs d'un
crime puisse être condamné
notre intérêt je le redis parce que j'ai
entendu
beaucoup de prises de position sur ce
sujet depuis quelques jours beaucoup
étaient empreintes de vraies inquiétudes
beaucoup étaient empreintes d'une vraie
hauteur de vue certaines étaient
empreintes parfois de très grande
facilité et d'une facilité confondante
je veux dire notre objectif encore une
fois c'est l'intérêt objectif de la
france c'est qu' il n'y ait pas de
dispersion de ces terroristes
nous prendrons donc toutes nos
responsabilités et nous mettons en place
tout ce qui est nécessaire pour faire en
sorte que si ces personnes venaient à
être expulsées elles puissent faire
l'objet de procédures judiciaires
extrêmement sévères de la part de notre
pays monsieur les ja monsieur le premier
ministre il faut dire la vérité aux
français
ces prisonniers seront ils échangent et
avant ce retour par les milices contre
des prisonniers détenus par beige
c'est un risque que vous n'avez pas cité
par ailleurs la réponse judiciaire en
faire les revenants majeur vous le savez
est tributaire de la preuve ils
tenteront tout pour minimiser leur rôle
un dossier judiciaire fragile c'est une
condamnation faibles assuré et un retour
dans la société à brève échéance ce
n'est pas acceptable
enfin c'est un problème dont l'europe
doit se saisir car les jihadistes
comporte de nouveaux de nombreux
européens dans leurs rangs la charte de
londres et le statut de rome
vous le savez le permettent nous parlons
ici de crimes de guerre de crimes contre
l'humanité et de génocide
je crois que votre volte face n'est que
le marqueur d'une certaine faiblesse de
la politique étrangère au levant ils ne
doivent pas revenir
merci les prochaines questions
d'actualité au gouvernement auront lieu
le 5 février nations six suspendus
jusqu'à 16 heures 20 pour la suite de
l'examen des projets de loi relatifs à
la croissance et la transformation des
entreprises séance est suspendue
et voilà pour ces questions d'actualité
du sénat au gouvernement où il a été
question de sujets internationaux et
notamment de la guerre en syrie avec 130
djihadiste français qui pourraient être
relâchés par les forces kurdes et
revenir en france avec une question du
sénateur les républicains pascal
allizard qui estime que ces djihadistes
ne doivent pas revenir en france car il
est car ils constituent un danger pour
la sécurité nationale
edouard philippe le premier ministre lui
a répondu en estimant qu'il fallait
éviter la dispersion sur le territoire
syrien de ces djihadistes et que si
jamais il était expulsé du territoire
syrien et qu'il venait en contact avec
les frontières françaises ces
djihadistes seraient arrêtés par les
autorités françaises
jugé et condamné sévèrement pour éviter
leur dispersion et puis il a été
question de la crise au venezuela et
notamment de la répression du président
nicholas maduro sur des centaines et des
milliers de manifestants dans son pays
le président du groupe les indépendants
au sénat claude malhuret a dénoncé cette
répression et à dénoncer le régime de
nicolás maduro un régime soutenu par un
certain jean luc mélenchon qualifié avec
humour par claude malhuret de lider
minimo claude malhuret qui a également
dénoncé l'arrestation de deux
journalistes français de l'émission
quotidien edouard philippe a annoncé que
le ministère des affaires étrangères
avait demandé la libération immédiate de
ces journalistes français voilà pour ces
deux moments forts de ces questions
d'actualité du sénat au gouvernement
merci à vous et alexandre pour toutes
ces précisions on va continuer
d'analyser cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement avec mon
invité à ce jeu le plaisir d'accueillir
un martin décidera bonjour vous êtes à
l'ère des yvelines beaucoup de questions
aujourd'hui à commencer par
l'interdiction des lanceurs de balles de
défense on sait qu'il a une proposition
de loi communiste qui sera débattue au
mois de mars prochain
le monde et gilet jaune qui continue un
sa mobilisation
chaque samedi et rythmée par une
nouvelle manifestation parfois de plus
en plus violente avec d'un côté et bien
allez policier et sept fuseaux de
contester des flashball est ce que vous
vous seriez favorable à leur
interdiction
alors je crois que de toute façon par
principe il faut condamner toutes les
violences quelles qu'elles soient d'où
qu'elles viennent
ça ça me paraît fondamental et je crois
que c'est quelque chose que nous
partageons tous collectivement
de ce point de vue s'agisse en fait des
flash-balls bien évidemment un usage non
conforme doit être condamné et doit être
évidemment regardé avec vigilance
toutefois il est vrai que ces polémiques
est réapparu suit en fait à certaines
manifestations à certains actes autour
des gels et jaune
je ne pense pas qu'il faille non plus
généraliser les ces mauvais usage il y
en aura il y en aura toujours
donc personnellement je pense qu'il ne
faut pas démunir nos forces de l'ordre
de ceux qui est aussi un moyen pour eux
de pouvoir être efficaces dans leur
mission et personnellement je moi je
suis pour ne pas déshabiller notre nos
forces de l'ordre et je ne suis pas
favorable
forcément à la suppression donc des
outils que notre police a aujourd'hui en
revanche bien évidemment il faut que
nous soyons tous collectivement
vigilants à leur usage marseille c'est
vrai que je vais vous faire réagir à un
autre sujet malade avant cela on va
retourner en salle des conférences et le
principe de cette émission puisque thème
tran huy et aux côtés du ministre en
charge des relations avec le parlement
marc fesneau
oui marc fesneau vous êtes déclaré
favorable à un retour partiel au cumul
des mandats notamment pour les maires de
petites villes
alors françois patriat a jugé ce matin
qu'on pouvait prévoir un seuil à 2500
habitants
que pensez vous de cette proposition moi
je pense qu'il faut que le débat se noue
c'est une
c'est une réflexion qui font qu'on porte
ça fait deux ans que la la fin du cumul
des mandats est à l'oeuvre et on voit
bien la fois ce que ça peut produire
dutil quand même on voit bien que
parfois le cumul d'un mandat d'un très
gros exécutif avec un mandat
parlementaire poser des questions de
disponibilité tout simplement et entend
les écueils qu'on a au travers de cette
affaire là c'est à dire le fait que deux
mondes sont en train de cohabiter
désormais alors qu'avant ils se
mélangent et le monde des élus locaux et
le monde des élus nationaux ce n'est pas
le seul fait du non cumul des fractures
qui se
vous verrez avec elle il faut regarder
ça avec tranquillité sans rentrer dans
la caricature j'ai pas dit que c'était
la seule question qui était en cause
mais en tout cas c'est une question
qu'il faut interroger tranquillement les
questions de seuils viendront peut-être
s'il ya la question est posée
je pense que c'est une question aussi
pour les territoires intermédiaire où
les territoires ruraux en particulier
qui était celle de dire est-ce que
compte tenu du fait que nous n'avons
plus de représentants nationaux ne
seront pas moins représentées dans un
état qui reste un état extrêmement
centralisé l'histoire française est une
histoire centralisée ce n'est pas un
état fédéral l'état français et donc a
besoin de représentation de ces
territoires et leurs réalités locales et
donc on va regarder c'est pas une
question simplement d'implication dans
le territoire je pense qu'on peut très
bien être élu national et percevoir la
réalité d'un territoire sans être élu
local
mais ce lien avait une utilité en tout
cas pour une part dans les assemblées
donc vous prévoyez plutôt une forme
d'exception plutôt pour les petites
villes hier non mais attendez on prévoit
rien simplement pause
on est à un moment de débat national le
président la république et pourtant la
république dans la république a évoqué
le premier ministre a évoqué aussi on
prévoit rien il faut que le débat se
nouent et c'est bien dans un moment où
on dit qu'on a des sujets qui doivent
pas porter de tabou qu'on puisse le
poser sur la table tranquillement arias
palin ya pas de polémique à voir faut
juste se poser des questions et dans le
moment qu'on vit se poser des questions
c'est une bonne chose que pensez vous du
fait qu'il ya de nombreux sénateurs ici
qui disent soir on revient complètement
sur le non cumul et tout le monde peut
cumuler soit on reste bien moi je pense
qu'il ya un chemin entre les deux oui et
qu' il n'est pas illogique que nous
posions la question disant voilà ce que
ça a apporté de positif la fin du cumul
et voilà peut-être les écueils il ya
peut-être d'autres solutions que ça
d'ailleurs qu'on a rencontrés au moment
où on voit comment ça se met en oeuvre
depuis 24 mois je pense que la question
n'est pas de revenir toujours en arrière
et de rld et faire ce que d'autres ont
fait mais peut-être en continue
d'évaluer et d'évoluer est-ce qu'en ce
moment très sensible du grand débat
après la crise des gilet jaune encore là
est ce que vraiment il faut rouvrir le
débat du non cumul
on sait qu'on est à la question pour les
citoyens du live ça n'est pas le cumul
qui est impopulaire
vous demanderez à des gens qui vivent
dans les territoires ruraux finalement
la figure du député maire ou du maire
adjoint député n'était pas une limite
c'est le cumul des indemnités voilà
voyez comprenez bien le sujet donc il
faut distinguer la question du cumul au
sens de le fait qu'on puisse être élu
local et le national et responsabilités
locales a besoin de retrouver mes sens
mais je pense qu'il faut et je préfère
rien je pose sur la table le débat parce
que je pense qu'il faut le faire avec
cette tranquillité là sans rentrer dans
la caricature et de ya la question du
cumul des indemnités par dessus
distinguons les deux on peut très bien
très drastiquement limiter le cumul des
indemnités est par ailleurs se dire que
c'est bien que des gens soient en
situation de responsabilité locale
les deux peuvent se combiner merci
beaucoup marc chesneau pour avoir
répondu à mes questions le débat est
donc ouvert un débat ouvert sur la
question du non cumul et d'éventuelles
dérogations
merci à vous cette réaction martin
décidera qu'est ce que c'est opportun
justement tam traduit le rappeler en
plein mouvement des gilet jaune de
rouvrir cette thématique du non cumul
des mandats alors je ne sais pas si
c'est opportun ou pas en tout cas c'est
une question qui se pose
vous savez bien que dans beaucoup de nos
territoires des cahiers dit de doléances
sont ouverts par les parlers par les
élus par les maires et on voit que c'est
un sujet effectivement le cumul des
mandats qui revient parfois je ne dirais
pas de façon forcément prégnant mais qui
revient donc c'est une question
effectivement à laquelle il ne faut pas
se refuser de répondre
j'observe au sérieux à l'oral vous
justement à proposer la possibilité d'un
cumul pour les maires des communes par
exemple avec ces seuils de 2500
habitants et je ne sais pas quel et les
noms seuil
je crois que ça a été bien exprimée par
marc raynaud je ne sais pas s'il ya un
véritablement un bon soyons un mauvais
seuil il a très bien fait le distinguo
entre cumul d'indemnités et cumul de
mandat qui est un vrai sujet et je
partage ce qui vient d'être dit c'est
que on confond parfois un petit peu les
deux donc je pense que il est important
notamment nous les sénateurs nous sommes
parfaitement nourrit de cela de nos
territoires il est important que nous
ayons un ancrage local et de proximité
donc de ce point de vue je trouve que
c'est dommage que beaucoup d'entre nous
ait été obligé de démissionner d'un
mandat exécutif
cela ne nous empêche pas bien évidemment
de rester conseiller de rester quand
même dans nos territoires mais je crois
qu'ils n'ont pas seulement vous l'avez
encore cela vous met pas de la même
manière puisque aujourd'hui vous savez
bien qu'on ne peut pas cumuler deux
exécutifs
or il est souvent important de savoir un
petit peu de quelle manière va
s'exprimer en réalité cette proximité de
quelle manière un élu quand il émet ou
quand il est conseiller municipal va
pouvoir porter un certain nombre de
sujets de son territoire
donc je crois qu'il ne faut pas
s'interdire ce débat là il faut bien
faire le distinguo entre bien évidemment
ce qui concerne
les indemnités de ce qui concerne
véritablement les engage à vous entendre
parlementaire vous le faites mais chez
les français c'est être plus compliqué
justement je veux pas voir de nouvelles
images de ce qu'on appelait les cumuls
air entre fois oui moi je crois qu'en
fait la vraie question qui se pose à
nous sait qui fait quoi et beaucoup de
nos concitoyens ne savent pas en réalité
ce que font leurs élus parfois ils
connaissent parfaitement les actions de
leurs mères de leurs élus locaux
parce que ce sont les élus de proximité
en revanche dès lors que vous vous
éloignez un tout petit peu de cette
proximité la même vis-à-vis du
département moi je rencontre des des
administrés des concitoyens qui ne
savent pas forcément qui fait quoi
je ne vous parle pas des parlementaires
et donc il ya une espèce de je pense de
confusion dans l'esprit de beaucoup de
nos concitoyens et le grand débat à cela
j'ai envie de dire comme peut-être en
tout cas je l'espère et je l'appelle de
tous mes voeux de nous permettre à un
moment donné d' expliquer très
clairement qu'il avait déserté ces
grands débats martens existe certaines
vertus il a certaines vertus
je ne suis pas une grande fan je vais
tout à fait franche avec vous mais les
choses sont posés à table là où j'estime
que c'est un tout petit peu enfin ça
pose question c'est que ça va dans
beaucoup de directions toutes très
différentes mais sur le fond ça permet
en même temps nous mêmes les élus et les
parlementaires de nous interroger sur
nos propres manières de fonctionner et
de partager ce que nous sommes censés
porter un tract qualité qui touche de
près le sénat ce sont les nouvelles
révélations au martinez y de mediapart
assure alexandre benalla jonquière soeur
aînée co rapporteur de la commission
d'enquêté parlementaire est d'ailleurs à
vos côtés mme tran huy jean pierre sueur
à quelle est votre réaction à ces
dernières révélations de mediapart on
découvre notamment et bien qu alexandre
ménard a été peut-être la cheville
ouvrière de contrat avec un oligarque
russe alors qu'il travaillait encore à
l'elysée qu'il a vu vincent kraz le 26
juillet en violation de son contrôle
judiciaire et qu'il y avait des liens
très forts qui sont restés avec l'elysée
après sa mise en examen
vous savez insisté comme nous à
l'audition publique qui a eu lieu lundi
dernier
au cours de laquelle monsieur benalla a
déclaré n'avoir pas eu d'activité de ce
type pendant qu'il était à l'elysée
autres addictions tonnelle non sur le
braz a dit que s'il avait créé une
nouvelle société
c'était une coïncidence et qu'il n'y
avait pas de relation
notre marge du rapport et ménez prend
connaissance comme tous mes collègues de
ce que publie aujourd'hui médiapart de
ce que publie le monde et je rappelle
simplement qu'il y à une loi et que
cette loi prévoit des sanctions très
lawn
lorsque l'on ment sous serment jusqu'à
deux ans de prison lorsque l'on ment
sous serment ça peut être cinq ans de
prison cinq ans de prison et une somme
importante 75000 euros d'amendé lorsque
l'on ment sous serment
nous avons publié notre rapport dans
quelques temps
et bien entendu nous sommes extrêmement
attentifs
à tout ce qui est dit et à tout ce qui
est induit par ce qui est 10e et qui
aujourd'hui paraît dans mediapart et
dans le monde entier vous pourriez
saisir la justice vous avertis c'est
cela et tant que nous prendrons les
décisions que la commission des lois
décidera de prendre et nous ferons des
propositions mais s'il est certain que
cette affaire est grave
nul ne peut le contester aujourd'hui
cette affaire est très grave et d'autre
part chacun a pu entendre les auditions
publiques
c'est important pour nous de faire des
auditions publiques car il doit y avoir
une transparence et bien merci beaucoup
d'anciens sert d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
merci beaucoup pour cette réaction je
vous propose d'ailleurs d'écouter une
partie de ces enregistrements révélés
par mediapart il ya quelques minutes à
présent c'est un cauchemar
c'est une bonne défense 26 ans qui
et pour des commissions d enquête
parlementaire qui bloque le
fonctionnement du parlement
cette démarche lui est mort doit aimer
et nerveusement mes amis marais mais
cette chute propulsait si on est bien
entouré d'une bande de débiles ici de
manière vraiment une crise qui s comment
ça va se passer quoi t'est-ce
marquillies cet album m'a dit écoute si
demain il ya vraiment un truc plus grave
être questionné voulons réagir comment
tout ça vous entendez alexandre benalla
martin de cédric sur ces enregistrements
et qui se vante d'avoir provoqué deux
commissions d'enquêté parlementaires
d'avoir bloqué le parlement comment
réagissez vous alors écoutez sur la
personne d'alexandre benalla je ne me
fais pas trop d'illusions si vous voulez
je vois là une péripétie 1
un nouvel épisode qui s'ouvre moi je
fais totalement confiance à notre
commission denquête pour mener jusqu'au
bout
voir s'il ya eu par jure pas enfin voir
quels éventuellement suites seront
données à toutes ces nouvelles
révélations qu'il faudra vérifier bien
évidemment en revanche ce qui m'inquiète
beaucoup plus c'est que ça révèle
quelque chose de notre de notre
gouvernance au plus haut de l'état et ça
pour le coup vous voyez ça ne me réjouit
pas beaucoup non pas que la ferme et
nahla me réjouisse énormément mais je
pense que là c'est ça révèle énormément
sur un mode de fonctionnement sûr
peut-être des amitiés sur peut-être des
protections qui s'exerce je dis tout
cela au conditionnel il faut il faut
laisser le tout cela se dérouler le plus
sereinement possible si cela est
toujours possible mais là encore je
crois que si cela s'avérait être vrai il
faudra se poser la question de
l'attitude au plus haut de plus haut de
nos instances un haut niveau de l'elysée
vis-à-vis aussi du parlement c'est
justement l'objectif de la commission d'
enquête parlementaire sur les
dysfonctionnements à la tête de l'elysée
votre collègue françois grosdidier qui
est membre de cette commission denquête
était au micro de thème traduit on
écoute ferraille sont tout de suite
françois grosdidier je voudrais votre
réaction est bien aux dernières
révélations de mediapart notamment sur
le fait que alexandre benalla était
impliqué selon médiapart dans les
contrats avec l'oligarque russe alors
même qu'il travaillait à l'elysée ça
c'est un mensonge de plus devant notre
commission puisqu'ils avaient juré le
contraire
ce qui est intéressant dans les
révélations médiapart c'est que ça
confirme le lien entre benalla et le
président la république les mêmes on a
l'impression que ce sont deux
adolescents
c'est important avec l'elysée qui ont
été maintenus alors même qu'il était le
meilleur tu va les bouffer on avec le
président de république et avec monsieur
benalla en fait deux adolescents qui
sont dans un sentiment de surpuissance
nos limites et qui défie le monde entier
et qui s'affranchissent de toute règle
et singulièrement d'état de droit c'est
exactement ce que nous avons c'est ce
que nous sentions des départs et entre
temps on a la confirmation comme on à
l'interview de monsieur cra dans charlie
hebdo qui révèle que c'était bien
monsieur benalla le patron de la
sécurité lizaine contrairement à tout ce
qui a été affirmé par les responsables
de l'elysée
donc effectivement les
les intuitions de la commission d'
enquête sénatoriale et elle est bonne
elle est à dire l se fonder sur des
faits sur déclarations des syndicats de
policiers sur les éléments matériels
comme l'arrêté du préfet de police
et on a la confirmation et ça va
certainement continuer la presse révèle
toujours des nouveaux éléments qui
confirment que l'elysée a menti alors
serait tellement plus simple que de dire
bas que ça avait dysfonctionné impôts
des pannes avec le staff de campagne et
s'occupait de la sécurité présidentielle
et que j'avais tirs cadrés depuis la
commission d'enquêté parlementaire que
peut-elle faire face à sale et mensonges
en castel ne peut qu elle est
impuissante aujourd'hui elle est
impuissante son travail c'est d'établir
la vérité dans qu'elle établisse la
vérité la commission d'enquêté
sénatoriale compte amasser de
l'assemblée aura fait la lumière sur les
événements après aux français d'en tirer
des conclusions et à la justice qui sera
certainement saisi pour et bien jugé de
tous les cas de parjure devant la
commission denquête merci beaucoup
françois grosdidier d'avoir répondu à
mes questions
il ya quelques instants du sénat c'est
l'examen de la loi pacte martin décidera
qu'on sait que la douane sénatoriale
s'est opposé à la privatisation
notamment d'aéroports de paris est ce
que ce n'est pas contradictoire avec la
doctrine finalement propre républicain
un peu plus libérale alors je crois qu'à
travers le dossier adp de toute façon
laissons se dérouler l'examen du texte
de loi mais à travers donc le sujet de
la priver des privatisations par d'onde
adp se pose la question si la
souverainté à un moment donné vous avez
vu aujourd'hui d'ailleurs au kg il ya
une question qui a porté sur l'aéroport
de toulouse vous comprenez bien toutes
les interrogations qui peuvent se
présenter à nous pour pour essayer de
comprendre et de voir quelles sont
réellement les les attendus et les
objectifs de notre exécutif aujourd'hui
autour de cela
dans le doute compte tenu de ce que nous
avons vécu par le passé il me semble
prudent
personnellement moi je suis contre la
privatisation d'un des pays les vrais je
suis l air nous sommes un certain nombre
parce que se posent à nous comme je
voulais dire une question de souverainté
aussi c'est quelque chose qui est très
important pour beaucoup de raisons
économiques bien sûr mais aussi de
véritablement de capacité et de hub en
fait en europe sur lesquelles il faut
que l'état puisse avoir la main eh bien
merci beaucoup a marqué notre invité
d'ailleurs bruno le maire à la maison
l'économie a été interrogé sur ce point
par dang tran huy je vous propose de
l'écouter
bruno le maire mardi en discussion
générale vous espériez à avoir des
discussions constructives avec les sénat
les avez vous eu sur les seuils relevés
par le sénat contre votre avis et quand
vous voyez l'opposition d'une bonne
partie des sénateurs droite comprise aux
privatisations
il ya eu des points positifs sur les
seuils il ya eu des améliorations côté
apporté d'autres avec lesquels je suis
en complet désaccord je pense que
relever le seuil de 50 à 100 pour la
représentation du personnel il faut bien
voir ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que des entreprises entre 50 et 100
salariés qui avaient un comité
représentant le personnel toute une
organisation pour les syndicats n'en
n'aurai plus moi je ne suis pas
favorable du tout à cela je pense qu'on
a besoin de dialogue social dans
l'entreprise et je ne crois absolument
pas opportun de relever le seuil de
représentativité de 50 à 100 salariés et
sur les privatisations comment
jugez-vous l'opposition de la droite
est-elle contradictoire avec les valeurs
de votre ancienne famille politique pour
vous nous verrons quelle sera l'issue
des discussions
ce que je veux dire simplement ce que je
me souviens d'un ancien candidat à la
primaire de la droite qui vais gagner
ces primaires qui disait qu'il voulait
engager des privatisations qu'il fallait
que l'état cède ses participations dans
un certain nombre d'entreprises pour
investir c'est exactement ce que nous
voulons faire et j'espère que les
républicains seront retrouvées ce qui
est leur cohérence idéologique pour
améliorer nos propositions se cessions
d'actifs
je suis tout à fait prêt et jean
françois husson le rapporteur a fait des
propositions très intéressante dans le
sens là à renforcer les garanties sur
les privatisations
nous nous voulons des privatisations qui
soit sûre pour nos compatriotes qui leur
donne des garanties sur les tarifs sur
les redevances et puis je rappelle que
rien ne changera notamment pour adp sur
le contrôle des frontières et sur les
aspects de sécurité mais j'espère que
les républicains avec le rapporteur jean
françois husson resteront cet esprit
constructif
pour améliorer nos propositions et pas
pour les détruire attendait ce qui en
dit on vend les bijoux de famille qui
avait une position très ferme
c'est une vision politique pour vous
nous verrons je veux pas préjuger ce que
sera le débat la seule chose dont je
suis convaincu c'est qu'aujourd'hui le
rôle de l'état ce n'est pas de gérer des
entreprises qui appartiennent au secteur
concurrentiel
parce que adp n'est pas un monopole je
rappelle qu'il ya beaucoup d'autres
possibilités pour les voyageurs et peut
se passer par londres ils peuvent passer
par francfort peut s'arrêter dans des
aéroports de province donc ce n'est pas
un monopole le contrôle des frontières
restent strictement du domaine de l'état
et de la souveraineté de l'état et
l'argent que nous allons récupérer à
servir à investir dans l'avenir des
français dans les technologies de
rupture tout cela ne devrait poser aucun
problème de fond aux républicains et
j'espère qu'ils reviendront ce point de
vue là à la sagesse alors hier le sénat
également bruno le maire a repoussé d'un
an
l'interdiction de certains ustensiles en
plastique à usage unique revenant sur
des dispositions votées avec la loi sur
l'alimentation est une mesure à laquelle
vous êtes favoris parce que cela va
rester à l'assemblée nationale fondre et
moi je souhaite parce que les
dispositions qui avait été voté
l'assemblée nationale avait été voté
contre l'avis du gouvernement et je
pense qu'il est très important de
trouver un bon équilibre entre la
transition énergétique la transition
économique pour protéger notre planète
tout le monde évidemment veut avancer
dans ce sens là et aussi la sauvegarde
est aussi la sauvegarde d'emplois parce
que j'estime est pas une question de
recul d'avancé simple à ce qu on veut
garder nos emplois et avoir des
transitions qui se fasse dans un temps
raisonnable
on voit bien que lorsqu'on va trop vite
qu'on veut accélérer les transformations
de manière trop précipitée à ça provoque
des blocages donc je préfère qu'on fasse
ça un bon rythme pour que les
entreprises puissent s'adapter plutôt
que de détruire des emplois brutalement
parce que derrière il ya des emplois il
ya des entreprises
il ya des usines donnons-nous un peu
plus de temps c'est ce qu' il a été
adopté au sénat pour que la
transformation se fasse dans de bonnes
conditions sans menacer l'emploi
merci beaucoup prennent à la merde
apprécié à mes questions cette édition
à vous de l'avoir suivi très bonne suite
à des programmes sur public sénat
[Musique]
on
amendement débat vote en séance
dans un instant ancien cadre dirigeant
d'alstom frédéric pierucci assure que
son emprisonnement pour corruption est
la conséquence de la fusion entre alstom
et général electric
retour avec lui sur cette affaire d'état
ou comment les états unis utilisent le
droit comme une arme économique droit de
suite présenté par jean-pierre gratien
ce soir à 20h30
permanence tagué voitures brûlées
slogans hostiles sur les ronds points
lors de leur élection les députés de la
majorité
aurait-il pu imaginer ce qui les
attendait je préfère avoir un dialogue
que les pétards des confettis ça n'ouvre
pas le dialogue est là il est présent il
a fait l'effort de venir
je pense que c'est un exercice politique
pas forcément facile comment reconquérir
la confiance face à cette crise elle
sait que le mag samedi à 13h30
[Musique]